I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi there.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入探讨办公室的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。你好。嗨。
You look so cute. I think you look cute. Well, it's on brand for today's episode. Because today it's Meet Cutes and Office Romances. But first, we have some fun shares for our top of show. Angela, do you want to go first? Because your share required some heavy lifting. It did require some heavy lifting.
你看上去真可爱。我觉得你看起来很可爱。嗯，这很符合今天节目的主题。因为今天是“浪漫邂逅与办公室恋情”。不过首先，我们要为节目开头分享一些有趣的事情。安吉拉，你想先说吗？因为你的分享需要费点力气。确实需要费点力气。
Shout out to Josh and Sam. Josh brought these in the house. We got this huge box delivery. And you guys, it is our Webby Awards. Yeah. For our whole team. Our whole team, Ainsley, Sam, Cassie, me and you, and I'm really proud of it. It is the 2025 People's Voice Award winner for podcast, shows and comedy.
向乔什和萨姆致敬。乔什把这些搬进了屋里。我们收到了一个巨大的快递箱。大家知道吗，这是我们的威比奖。是的。为了我们整个团队。我们整个团队，艾恩斯利、萨姆、卡西、我还有你，我真的为它感到骄傲。这是2025年人民之声奖播客、节目和喜剧类的得主。
Office Ladies won. Woohoo! So I think we should share that we have Cassie to thank for this award in a big way because the way this works with the Webby Awards is you get to like submit an episode. Yes, for consideration of being nominated. And the episode that we submitted was our Star Wars holiday special breakdown, which was Cassie's idea. Cassie, I would have never watched that, and I'm a Star Wars fan, had you not suggested it. You're welcome. Thank you.
《办公室女士》获奖了！呜呼！所以我认为我们应该分享一个事实，那就是我们在很大程度上要感谢卡西获得这个奖项，因为威比奖的运作方式是你可以提交一集节目。是的，为了考虑获得提名。而我们提交的那集节目是我们的《星球大战》假期特别节目解析，那是卡西的主意。卡西，要不是你提议，我绝不会看那个，而且我还是个《星球大战》迷。不客气。谢谢。
It really is the gift that keeps on giving. I might have to watch it every Christmas now. I hear you. I agree. And then Ainsley, I think we owe you a debt for outlining the Star Wars episode. I'd say it was my pleasure, but, you know, it was. It was a pleasure. It was very fun working on the episode with all of you. But while you're here, I do have a question for you. Of all the crazy things we've asked you to outline for us over these many years, what has been the craziest
这真的是一份不断带来惊喜的礼物。我现在可能每年圣诞节都得看一遍了。我懂的。我同意。然后是艾恩斯利，我想我们得感谢你为《星球大战》那集节目写了大纲。我本想说这是我的荣幸，但是，你知道的，确实如此。这是我的荣幸。和大家一起制作这集节目非常有趣。但趁你在这儿，我确实有个问题想问你。在这些年来我们要求你为我们写大纲的那么多疯狂的事情中，对你来说最疯狂的是哪一件？
for you? Was it the Star Wars or was it something else? I would say the first seven minutes of just wookie speak has to take the game. Okay. And you know, know what I loved about your outline for it is when I could see your personality come through, like you would put in parentheses, they're still dancing. Yeah. For some reason, this is happening. Yes, exactly. It's very fun. So that's the episode that got us the nomination. And then, of course, all of you all voted. And that's how we got our award. And thank you so much. Thank you so much. And thank you to everyone who messaged us. I voted. I voted. Every time I saw that. It made my heart happy. Well, thank you for bringing those in today, Ang. I can't wait to put mine
是《星球大战》还是别的什么？我想前七分钟全都是武技语，这绝对拔得头筹。好的。你知道我最喜欢你写的什么大纲内容吗？就是当能看到你的个性流露出来的时候，比如你会用括号写着：他们还在跳舞。是的。不知何故，这件事发生了。是的，没错。非常有趣。所以这就是为我们赢得提名的那一集。然后，当然，你们所有人都投票了。我们就是这样拿到这个奖的，非常感谢你们。非常感谢你们。也谢谢所有给我们发消息的人。我投了。我投了。每次看到那个我都觉得心里暖洋洋的。安吉，谢谢你今天把这些搬来，我都等不及把它摆在
on my shelf in my office. I love this award. Me too. And thank you, Sam, for, I don't know how you, like, it was like a game of jinga, how you, like, stacked all the boxes and carried them up. Yep, this is what I've been training for. There it is. There it is. Human jingo. I have some office real estate news. Oh, yes. Share. Michael Scott's condo is up for sale, everyone. In fact, there's a good chance that by the time you hear this podcast, it will have sold because the listing does say buyer pending. But let me tell you about it.
办公室的架子上了。我太喜欢这个奖了。我也是，谢谢萨姆，因为，我不知道你是怎么做到的，就像玩叠叠乐一样，你怎么把所有箱子叠起来并搬上来的。没错，这就是我一直在训练的项目。就是这样。就是这样。真人叠叠乐。我有一些办公室房地产的新闻。哦，耶。分享一下。迈克尔·斯科特的公寓要出售了，各位。事实上，很有可能当你听到这个播客时，它已经卖出去了，因为房源信息上确实写着买家待定。但让我跟你们讲讲它吧。
It is 7303 Bonnie Place and Receita, California, and it's currently priced at $710,000. It features three bedrooms, three bathrooms, with 1,458 square feet of living space plus a back patio two car garage and a gated entryway into the development, which I think this is a very good feature that they should really underline and put in bold in the listing because now everyone knows where this is. Right. And this way maybe people aren't just parked right in front of your house getting a picture with Michael's condo. Yeah, I mean, I remember when we shot there, we had to go through this like gated entry. You know, I used to live by the Brady Bunch house. Oh, did people come by all the time? Literally like those star van tours would come by. And people would unload from the bus and take pictures in front of it. And I know that this happens at Jim and Pam's house. Oh, and someone lives there. Yeah. People go take a picture in front of it. But for this condo, the listing does say this, quote, this home is a great starter home or a downsized home as it can be easily managed and maintained. This,
它位于加利福尼亚州雷西达邦尼广场7303号，目前的标价是710,000美元。它拥有三间卧室、三间浴室，居住面积为1,458平方英尺，外加一个后院露台、一个两车位车库以及通往小区的带门入口，我认为这是一个非常好的特点，他们真的应该在房源信息中加上下划线并加粗，因为现在每个人都知道这是哪里了。对的。这样也许人们就不会只是把车停在你的房子前面，然后跟迈克尔的公寓合影了。对，我的意思是，我记得我们当时在那里拍摄时，我们必须通过这样一个带门的入口。你知道的，我以前住在《脱线家族》的房子旁边。哦，人们总是来参观吗？简直就像那些明星观光团的厢型车会开过来一样。人们会从车上下来，在它前面拍照。我知道吉姆和帕姆的家里也会发生这种事。哦，而且有人住在那里。对。人们去它前面拍照。但对于这套公寓，房源信息确实是这样写的，引述如下：“这个家是一个极好的首套房或是缩转型住房，因为它可以轻松管理和维护。”这个
properties claim to fame, it was the site for the whole episode dinner party of the show The Office. Season 4, episode 13. I mean, who could ever forget that one? Well, you know, I follow Zillow Gone Wild. I love this Instagram account. And they post kind of like real estate properties that have a little bit of a, huh? Like sometimes you look at them, you're like, what's happening here? It's a really fun follow. And they posted photos of the condo. And the caption just simply said, this home seems like a nice place to have a dinner party. And I was just scrolling through, like, quickly, and I looked at it. And I commented, wow, I thought that looked familiar. And they were like, oh, my gosh, they reposted that. Because I didn't know right away.
房产的名气来源，它是电视剧《办公室》第四季第13集整集“晚宴派对”的拍摄地。我的天，谁能忘得了那一集？好吧，你知道的，我关注了“Zillow疯狂往事”账号。我喜欢这个Instagram账号。他们会发布一些有点“啊？”的房地产物业。就像有时你看着它们，你会想：这儿到底在发生什么？关注这个账号真的很有趣。他们发布了这套公寓的照片。而配文很简单，上面写着：“这个家看起来像是举办晚宴派对的好地方。”我当时只是在快速浏览，然后我看了看。我评论道：“哇，我觉得这看起来好眼熟。”他们就说：“哦，天哪，他们转发了那个。”因为我当时没有马上认出来。
You know, I didn't read the caption right away. Well, they post photos of what it looks like today. And it was crazy to look at them. There's no tiny flat screen TV above the fireplace, though. just a really nice piece of art in a frame. Is there a neon beer sign? No. There's like a sort of, I don't know what you would call it, like an iron work piece of art there. Very classy. Sure.
你知道的，我没有马上看配文。好吧，他们发布了它如今样子的照片。看着这些照片太疯狂了。壁炉上方没有那个小小的平板电视了，只有一个非常漂亮的框裱艺术品。有霓虹啤酒招牌吗？没有。那里有某种，我不知道该怎么称呼它，类似于铁艺的艺术品。非常高档。当然。
There are several candles. Oh, Jan. Jan would be so happy. Yeah, there's one in the center of the coffee table and then there's a bunch in the dining room. I mean, this is all I could think of. When I was looking at these pictures, I can't imagine what it would be like to actually tour the place. I was also like looking at the bedrooms. I'm like, oh, no bench at the end of the bend.
有几根蜡烛。哦，简。简一定会非常高兴。是的，咖啡桌正中央有一根，然后餐厅里还有一堆。我的天，这就是我能想到的全部了。当我看着这些照片时，我无法想象亲自去实地参观会是什么样的。我还看了看卧室。我想，哦，床尾没有长凳。
No, no. So on the actual Zillow site, like not Zillow gone wild. Right, right. They also put this in the listing. They said this property has several, quote, famous neighbors inside the complex, including Johnny Depp and M. Knight Sharmelon. Because these are, remember, like Michael thinks these guys might live there? Yeah.
没有，没有。所以在真正的Zillow网站上——不是Zillow疯狂往事，而是那个真的——他们也在房源信息里写了这一点。他们说这个物业在小区内有几个所谓的“名人邻居”，包括约翰尼·德普和M·奈特·沙马兰。因为这些是，你们还记得吗，迈克尔觉得这些家伙可能住在那里？对。
I mean, they don't. But that's so fun. And like a clever little take on it for the website. They were having a lot of fun with it. Okay. One last thing before we go to break, we have some exciting Office Ladies Network news. Mm-hmm. So for a while now, we have wanted to add another show to our network.
我的意思是，他们并没有。但这太有趣了，而且这是网站的一个聪明的小梗。他们拿这个开了很多玩笑。好吧，在我们进广告前还有最后一件事，我们有一些令人兴奋的“办公室女士”网络的好消息。嗯哼。所以有一段时间以来，我们一直想在我们的网络中加入另一档节目。
That's right. We started the Office Ladies Network with The Lazy Genius. But just a few months later, I got my breast cancer diagnosis and I went into treatment. So we kind of had to put a pause on growing our network for a beat. But now that the bulk of my treatment is over, I've got my stamina back, we were able to get back to our dream of growing our network. And we have loved having the lazy genius on our network. We love Kendra. We love the community that listens to her podcast. And we were trying to find the next good fit for our office ladies listeners. Yeah, we were really looking for a great podcast that was also going to inspire that great community.
没错。我们和《懒惰天才》一起创立了“办公室女士”网络。但仅仅几个月后，我被诊断出乳腺癌，并开始接受治疗。所以我们不得不暂停发展我们的网络一段时间。但现在我大部分的治疗都结束了，我的体力也恢复了，我们得以重拾发展我们网络的梦想。我们一直很喜欢《懒惰天才》加入我们的网络。我们喜欢肯德拉。我们喜欢听她播客的这个社群。我们一直在努力为我们的“办公室女士”听众寻找下一个绝佳的人选。是的，我们一直在寻找一个伟大的播客，它也将激发那个伟大的社群。
Well, we are thrilled to share that the next podcast we are adding to our network is a fantastic rewatch podcast called How We Made Your Mother. It is hosted by Josh Radner, who played Ted Mosby on the Emmy-nominated CBS sitcom How I Met Your Mother and the series co-creator Craig Thomas. If you're a fan of how I met your mother or if you're just a fan of hearing like the inner workings of how a TV show is made, then this is the podcast for you. Craig and Josh, I think maybe because one is an actor and one was a co-creator, you're getting both sides of the story in each episode. Yeah, you get very two distinct perspectives, which I loved. And they also have a fun rapport and fantastic interviews. I'm really loving their podcasts, and I can't wait for you all to listen.
好吧，我们非常高兴地与大家分享，我们网络中加入的下一档节目是一档极棒的重温播客，名为《我们是如何创造你母亲的》。它由在获得艾美奖提名的CBS情景喜剧《老爸老妈的浪漫史》中饰演泰德·莫斯比的乔什·拉德纳以及该剧的联合创作者克雷格·托马斯共同主持。如果你是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的粉丝，或者你只是喜欢听电视剧是如何制作的幕后运作的粉丝，那么这就是适合你的播客。克雷格和乔什，我想也许是因为一个是演员，一个是联合创作者，你在每一集里都能听到故事的两个方面。是的，你能得到两个截然不同的视角，我很喜欢这一点。而且他们之间也有有趣的默契和极棒的访谈。我真的很喜欢他们的播客，我等不及你们去听了。
So far, they have broken down every episode in season one. And like you said, Angela, they've had some great interviews. I absolutely love their interview with Kobe Smolders. Now they are starting season two. Yeah, and we're going to do a collab with them coming up. You know, sort of how we did the one with the PodMeets World folks. We're going to have them on to discuss an episode of the office. And then we're going to go on their podcast to discuss an episode of how I met your mother.
到目前为止，他们已经剖析了第一季的每一集。就像你说的，安吉拉，他们做了一些很棒的访谈。我绝对喜欢他们对科比·史姆德斯的访谈。现在他们开始第二季了。是的，接下来我们要和他们合作推出一个联动节目。你知道的，有点像我们和《与世界共度播客》的伙伴们做的那样。我们要请他们来讨论《办公室》的一集。然后我们要去他们的播客讨论《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的一集。
So please check it out. Season two starts Monday, October 20th. But if you want to get caught up, you can start listening now. You can find it wherever you get your podcasts. And we've also added a new team member to office ladies, everyone. Colin Anderson is with us now as our new head of network development. Yes, you might remember Colin from our Friday chit-chat. We discussed his kidney stone.
所以请去收听吧。第二季于10月20日星期一开播。但如果你想补上进度，现在就可以开始听了。你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它。而且我们还为“办公室女士”团队增加了一位新成员，各位。科林·安德森现在加入了我们，担任我们新的网络发展主管。是的，你们可能还记得周五闲聊里的科林。我们讨论过他的肾结石。
And you know, we met Colin years ago at Earwolf and we're so excited to be working with him again. And hopefully, because of Colin, you won't have to wait as long for our next new Office Ladies Network show. All right. Well, let's take a break because I'm ready for some romance and meet cutes. Well, listen, let's jump into the topic at hand, Meet Cutes and Office Romances. There are so many romances on the office. I mean, there's lots of coupledom, lady, and we sort of thought we had to dedicate a whole episode to them. Yeah, we asked Ainsley to do a little deep dive on office romances, but then I did a little research myself as well. Angela, do you know which office character had the most romances on the show?
你知道的，我们多年前在Earwolf认识了科林，我们非常高兴能再次与他合作。希望因为科林的加入，你们不用等那么久就能看到我们“办公室女士”网络的下一档新节目了。好了，让我们休息一下，因为我准备好迎接一些浪漫和浪漫邂逅了。好吧，听着，让我们直接进入手头的话题，浪漫邂逅与办公室恋情。办公室里有那么多的恋情。我的天，有很多伴侣组合，女士，我们觉得我们应该为他们专门做一整集节目。是的，我们请艾恩斯利对办公室恋情进行了一次深入探讨，但随后我自己也做了一些研究。安吉拉，你知道办公室里哪个角色在剧中的恋情最多吗？
Sam, Cassie, I open it up to you as well. I mean, I'm going to guess Angela Martin. I'm going to guess Angela Martin, too. Okay. Actually, Cassie? No, I'm going to change it. Sam's changing. To Michael.
萨姆，卡西，我也把这个问题抛给你们。我的意思，我猜是安吉拉·马丁。我也猜是安吉拉·马丁。好的。其实，卡西？不，我要换了。萨姆要换了。选迈克尔。
Oh, okay. Cassie, where do you want to be in this? Yeah, I think I'm leaning towards Michael as well. The answer is Michael. Yeah. He had both of the most. major romances and what I would categorize as flings or short-term romances, can you name his major romances? His major romances would be Pam's mom. That's the first one that comes to
哦，好吧。卡西，你想选谁？对，我觉得我也倾向于迈克尔。答案就是迈克尔。耶。他既有最重大的恋情，也有我归类为逢场作戏或短期的恋情，你能说出他重大的恋情有哪些吗？他重大的恋情会是帕姆的妈妈。那是第一个浮现在我脑海里的。
my. Yeah. No, I mean, Holly's not the love of his life. No, no, no, no. I'm leading with like all the randos. Okay. Leading with randos. Leading with randos. Also, obviously, Jan. What's her name from the hotel, concierge? Marie. Yes. The real estate agent, played by his real wife, Carol. Who is the bar owner? Yes.
是的。不，我是说，霍莉不是他一生的挚爱。不，不，不，不。我先说所有那些路人。好的，从路人说起。从路人说起。还有，显然是简。酒店礼宾叫什么名字？玛丽。是的。房地产经纪人，由他的现实生活中的妻子卡罗尔扮演。酒吧老板是谁？是的。
Donna, date mic. I mean, obviously, Holly. Who else? Yeah, you've named the big ones. But then there are all the people he tried to date unsuccessfully. That's a whole list in and of itself. I mean, would that include Pam? That is okay.
唐娜，约会麦克。显然还有霍莉。还有谁？对，你已经说出那些重大的了。但接着还有所有那些他试图约会却没有成功的人。光是这个就是一个长长的清单。我的意思，那会包括帕姆吗？那是可以的。
That came up in my research because he does throw a couple of like half passes at Pam, doesn't he? Like at Diwali? Yes, 100%. Yeah. And he makes comments to her like, in another life, if things were different, maybe you and I. And she's like, in no life is there a you and I. All right. Who else?
这在我的研究中出现过，因为他对帕姆确实抛出了几次半心半意的追求，不是吗？比如在排灯节？是的，百分之百。是的。他会对她说这样的话：“在另一种生活中，如果情况不同，也许你和我……”而她说：“在任何生活中都没有你和我。”好吧。还有谁？
Okay. Pam's landlord. Yes, Pam's landlord. Oh, right. So cringy. Yes. The Benny Hana waitresses. That was a crash and burn.
好吧。帕姆的房东。是的，帕姆的房东。哦，对了。太尴尬了。是的。贝尼汉纳餐厅的服务员。那是一场惨败。
The girl from Blood Drive. Oh. Oh, that's... Oh, I loved that scene. I know. And then also chair model. Chair model broke his heart. That was a whole episode.
《献血》那一集里的女孩。哦。哦，那……哦，我太喜欢那一幕了。我知道。还有椅子模特。椅子模特伤了他的心。那是完整的一集。
I love chair model. That makes me want to go back and rewatch that. I know. So Michael has. the most romances. And then it's like a big tie for who's next. Everybody in this list had like three major romances. Okay. I have a little list for you, lady. What is it? So there are so many favorite The Office romance lists online, like actual list of romances that fans really connect to. But there are 10 romantic scenes that everyone keeps coming back to,
我爱椅子模特。这让我想回去重温那一集。我知道。所以迈克尔拥有的恋情最多。然后接下来的排名不分先后。这个名单上的每个人都有大约三段重大恋情。好的。我为你准备了一个小清单，女士。是什么？所以网上有那么多最喜欢的《办公室》恋情清单，就像粉丝们真正产生共鸣的实际恋情清单。但有10个浪漫场景是每个人都会不断重温的，
to the internet, these are scenes that fans watch over and over. Are you ready? Yes. Number one, Jim's video to Pam. Oh. Yeah. The compilation of their love. Yes.
在互联网上，这些是粉丝们一遍又一扁观看的场景。准备好了吗？是的。第一名，吉姆给帕姆的视频。哦。是的。他们爱情的剪辑。是的。
That was an AARM. Then I thought this was great. This was number two. When Bob pays $1,000 to hug Phyllis. Hmm. That was so sweet. In crime aid. In crime aid, he got into like a whole like bidding war with Twight.
那是AARM。然后我觉得这个很棒。这是第二名。当鲍勃花1000美元拥抱菲利斯时。嗯。那太甜蜜了。在《犯罪援助》中。在《犯罪援助》中，他和德怀特陷入了一场竞标战。
number three when Dwight proposes to Angela okay am I crazy so that's also an AARM Jim's video to Pam and then Dwight's proposal at Angela what does it say about me that the way to my heart is Dwight's proposal more than the video the sentimental video I love just like the giant romantic gesture with all the like clunky like yes it was very emotional too. Yes. So raw. So raw. Well, you'll hear later. I pulled a clip of my favorite like meet cute and a romantic comedy and it has some elements of Dwight Angela, I think. Well, I have two clips to play as well at the end of this list and one of them is Dwight's proposal. I love it. I can't wait to hear it. So we had same brain there. And also the video is really touching. But as I have learned, this is an audio podcast. So I did not pick the video as a clip. Number four, Andy's 12 Days of Christmas for Erin. Oh, with the drum line at the end.
第三名，当德怀特向安吉拉求婚时。好吧，我是疯了吗？这也是在AARM里，吉姆给帕姆的视频，然后是德怀特向安吉拉求婚。通往我内心的途径居然是德怀特的求婚，而不是那个感伤的视频，这说明我是个什么样的人？我就是喜欢那种宏大的浪漫姿态，配上所有笨拙的……是的，也非常情绪化。是的。那么真实。那么真实。好吧，你们稍后会听到。我剪辑了我最喜欢的一段浪漫喜剧里的浪漫邂逅片段，我想它有一些德怀特和安吉拉的元素。好吧，在这份名单的最后，我也有两个片段要播放，其中之一就是德怀特的求婚。我太喜欢了。我等不及要听了。所以我们俩想到一块儿去了。而且那段视频真的很感人。但正如我所知，这是一个音频播客。所以我没有把视频选为剪辑。第四名，安迪为艾琳准备的圣诞节的12天。哦，最后还有鼓乐队。
With the drum line. Yes. Number five, Jim's Wedding Toast to Pam. My gosh, is it bad? I don't remember it. What does he say? Oh, it's so great, lady. It is so great. In fact, that is one of my clips.
带着鼓乐队。是的。第五名，吉姆在帕姆婚礼上的祝酒词。天哪，是不是很糟糕？我不记得了。他说什么了？哦，太棒了，女士。真的是太棒了。事实上，那正是我的片段之一。
Oh, so, okay, thank you. This is working out pretty good. I'm playing two of the ones you're most curious about. Okay, number six, when Jim dresses as Popeye, and he dresses Cece as Sweet P for Pam. I love that. That's pretty sweet. Number seven, when Michael proposes to Holly, I mean, so great. Number eight, Dwight and Angela's actual wedding.
哦，所以，好吧，谢谢。这进展得挺不错。我正要播放其中两个你最好奇的。好吧，第六名，当吉姆打扮成大力水手，他把西西打扮成甜豌豆送给帕姆。我太喜欢了。那挺甜蜜的。第七名，当迈克尔向霍莉求婚时。我的天，太棒了。第八名，德怀特和安吉拉真正的婚礼。
And in this article, it says many scenes from this one are fan favorites, but in particular, Dwight and Angela's first dance. When he, like, picks her up. Yes. Which was an improv, right? Yes. I mean, sort of. Her legs aren't working because they're very tired from being in the trunk. Yes. Basically, our first dance was going to be kind of clunky because Angela can't really, like, use her feet. And so Dwight was going to have to kind of maneuver her. But him picking me up and doing the tango and swinging me around, that was rain.
在这篇文章里，它说这里的许多场景都是粉丝的最爱，但特别是德怀特和安吉拉的第一支舞。当他像这样抱起她时。是的。那是即兴发挥，对吧？是的。我的意思是，算是吧。她的腿不好使，因为待在后备箱里太累了。是的。基本上，我们的第一支舞会有点笨拙，因为安吉拉真的无法使用她的双脚。所以德怀特不得不顺势抱住她。但他抱起我，跳探戈，把我转来转去，那是雷恩。
He improvised that and I just went with it. And I sort of stuck my legs out so they would fly around. Yes. Number nine, when Michael quits his job for Holly. They think that's a very romantic moment. And number 10, when Jim proposes to Pam in the rainstorm at the gas station. Yeah, that's a nice one. Yeah. But I thought, since it is our podcast, I would pick a Jim and Pam moment and a Dwight and Angela moment.
他那是即兴发挥，我只是顺着他演。我顺势把双腿伸直，好让它们飞舞起来。是的。第九名，当迈克尔为了霍莉辞职时。他们认为那是一个非常浪漫的时刻。第十名，当吉姆在加油站的暴雨中向帕姆求婚时。对，那是美好的一幕。是的。但我想，既然这是我们的播客，我应该挑选一个吉姆和帕姆的时刻以及一个德怀特和安吉拉的时刻。
So let's hear that toast that Jim makes to Pam at their rehearsal dinner. All right. Hey, everyone. Thanks for coming. Yes. Oh, thanks, Pete. That was really nice. I just want to say how happy we are that all of you are here tonight, and I want to especially thank those of you who have traveled from far away to be here with us tonight, especially the Florida cousins, who obviously can't take a hint. Four years ago, I was just a guy who had a crush on a girl who had a boyfriend,
所以让我们来听听吉姆在他们的彩排晚宴上对帕姆说的祝酒词。好的。大家好。谢谢你们的到来。是的。哦，谢谢皮特。那真的很棒。我只想说，大家今晚能来到这里，我们感到多么高兴，我尤其要感谢那些从远道而来今晚和我们在一起的人，特别是佛罗里达的表亲们，他们显然没听懂暗示。四年前，我只是一个对一个有男朋友的女孩有好感的家伙，
and I had to do the hardest thing that I've ever had to do, which was just to wait. Don't get me wrong. I flirted with her. Pam, I can now admit in front of friends and family that I do know how to make a photocopy. Didn't need your help that many times. And do you remember how long it took you to teach me how to drive stick? Like a year. I've been driving stick since high school. So, yes, yes. For a really long time, that's all I had. I just had little moments with a girl who saw me as a friend. And a lot of people told me I was crazy to wait this long for a day. date with a girl who I worked with, but I think even then I knew that I was waiting for my wife. So I would like to propose a toast. So if you'd all raise your glasses, not Pam, for obvious
而我不得不做我这辈子做过的最艰难的事情，那就是等待。别误会我。我调戏过她。帕姆，我现在可以在朋友和家人面前承认，我确实知道怎么复印。不需要你帮我那么多回。你还记得你花了我多长时间教我开手动档吗？差不多一年。我从高中起就会开手动档了。所以，是的，是的。在很长一段时间里，我只有这些。我只有和那个把我当成朋友的女孩在一起的微小时刻。很多人告诉我，我太疯狂了，竟然等这么久去和
reasons, but everyone else, if you would raise your glasses. Oh, for obvious reasons. And then, of course, this lovely toast goes off the rails because Nana's like, why? Why? And then Jim starts like, just completely flubbing. And then Michael, of all people, decides he's going to save it. And it's just a train wreck. But that toast is so lovely. It's really sweet. Really, really sweet.
一个和我一起工作的女孩约会，但我想即使在那个时候我也知道，我在等待我的妻子。所以我想要提议祝酒。所以如果大家能举起酒杯，帕姆除外，原因显而易见，但其他人，如果你们能举起酒杯。哦，原因显而易见。然后，当然，这个可爱的祝酒词就彻底失控了，因为奶奶说：为什么？为什么？然后吉姆开始完全结巴。接着迈克尔，偏偏是迈克尔，决定他要去拯救这个局面。简直就是一场车祸。但那段祝酒词太可爱了。真的很甜。真的，真的非常甜。
And now let's hear Dwight's proposal to Angela. It starts with him running her off the road. Pull over. Why? Move to the side of the road. Why? Hold over! What is Dwight?
现在让我们听听德怀特向安吉拉求婚。它以他把她的车逼停在路边开始。靠边停车。为什么？把车开到路边。为什么？停下来！德怀特到底在搞什么鬼？
Dwight? What the f*** is your problem? Who drives like that? I love you. And I don't care the penelps not my son. I will raise a hundred children with a hundred of your lovers if it means I can be with you. Can you put that down?
德怀特？你特么有什么毛病？谁这样开车？我爱。我不在乎菲利普是不是我的儿子。如果这意味着我能和你在一起，我愿意和你的上百个情人抚养上百个孩子。你能把它放下吗？
This expresses how loudly I love you. It's too loud. This is a ring. Taken from the buttocks of my grandmother. Put there by the gangster patriarch of the Kors dynasty. Melted in a foundry run by Mennonites. Okay. Yes. Yes, I will.
这表达了我有多么深爱着你。声音太大了。这是一枚戒指。取自于我祖母的臀部。由科尔斯家族的黑帮大家长放入那里。在门诺派教徒经营的铸造厂里熔化。好吧。是的。是的，我愿意。
You. I love you. I love you. And I lie to you. I lied to you. What? Phillips, your son. What?
你。我爱你。我爱你。我向你撒了谎。我向你撒了谎。什么？菲利普，你的儿子。什么？
Why would you say that? I just needed you to want to marry me because you wanted to marry me. Get out! I'm a dad! You're a dad! I mean, what great writing. Such good writing. That's probably why I like that proposal so much because I just, I love the poetic writing of that.
你为什么这么说？我只是需要你想和我结婚，是因为你想和我结婚。滚出去！我是个父亲！你是个父亲！我的天，多么棒的编剧。写得太好了。这大概就是为什么我那么喜欢那个求婚的原因，因为我就是，我爱那里面充满诗意的台词。
Yeah. I mean, I love the sentimentality of what Jim says. It's so from the heart. It's so beautiful. But, man, that is a good scene. Yeah. Both of those are so good. And we were just so lucky, man, to get to say those words and act out those scenes. It's, they are. They hold up. I get why they made the list. Well, you know, the office was also quite famous for dysfunctional relationships. Mm-hmm. There were a few. There were many. Who do you think had the most dysfunctional relationship on the office? Oh. Like who springs to mind? I mean, once again, I don't know, but like Angela and the senator and then Andy and Oscar, it's like, she had some crazy dysfunctional stuff, but then so did Michael.
是的。我的意思是，我喜欢吉姆所说的话中的那种感伤。太发自内心了。太美了。但是，天哪，那真是一场好戏。是的。这两个都太棒了。我们当时真的是太幸运了，能够说出那些台词并演好那些场景。它们确实如此。经得起时间的考验。我理解为什么它们能上榜。好吧，你知道的，办公室也因不健康的恋爱关系而相当出名。嗯哼。有那么一些。有很多。你觉得办公室里谁的恋爱关系最不健康？哦。比如谁最先跳进脑海？我的意思是，又来了，我不知道，比如安吉拉和参议员，然后是安迪和奥斯卡，就像是，她有一些疯狂的不健康的事情，但迈克尔也是。
I don't know. Are they a tie again? I don't know. This is just a discussion. I mean, there's Michael and Jan. Oh, so dysfunctional. Kelly and Ryan. Very dysfunctional. I did put Angela Andy on my personal list. Yes. I would put Angela and Andy and Angela and the senator. Yeah. What about Stanley, Cynthia, and Terry? Oh, man. Yeah. Stanley. I also put down Jan and Clark. Yes. I'm not sure what really happened there. Yes. Yeah. I mean, you know, and Michael and Pam's mom. I don't see. That's the thing. Like, I think.
我不知道。他们又并列了吗？我不知道。这只是一场讨论。我的意思是，有迈克尔和简。哦，太不健康了。凯利和瑞恩。非常不健康。我确实把安吉拉和安迪放到了我的个人名单上。是的。我会把安吉拉和安迪以及安吉拉和参议员放进去。还有斯坦利、辛西娅和特里？哦，天哪。是的，斯坦利。我还写下了简和克拉克。是的。我不确定那里到底发生了什么。是的。我的意思是，你知道的，还有迈克尔和帕姆的妈妈。我不觉得。这就是问题所在。就像，我觉得
think it was not great because it was Pam's mom, but they seemed to have a sweet relationship, although when it was over, Michael could barely ever remember that it happened. Also, he just turned on her so fast. He's like really stone cold dumped her. I know. I have a real life office romance I can share from history. From history. From history. I love a story from history. Yes. So you know Marie Curie. famous scientist, first woman to win a Nobel Prize. Yes. Also, the first person and only woman to win two Nobel Prizes in her lifetime.
这不太好，因为那是帕姆的妈妈，但他们似乎有一段甜蜜的感情，尽管当它结束时，迈克尔几乎记不起它曾经发生过。而且他翻脸翻得太快了。他就像是个冷血动物一样甩了她。我知道。我有一个可以分享的历史上的真实办公室恋情。从历史上。从历史上。我喜欢历史上的故事。是的。所以你知道玛丽·居里。著名的科学家，第一位获得诺贝尔奖的女性。是的。也是有史以来第一位也是唯一一位在其一生中赢得两次诺贝尔奖的人。
But she had a real-life office romance with her husband, Pierre, who was also a scientist. They met doing science, like in the laboratory. I love when you use the term doing something. We do Game of Thrones. So we're doing science. We're doing our podcast. Yes. We're doing it.
但她和她的丈夫皮埃尔有一段现实生活中的办公室恋情，皮埃尔也是一位科学家。他们是通过做科学研究认识的，就像在实验室里一样。我喜欢当你使用“做某事”这个词的时候。我们在做《权力的游戏》。所以我们在做科学。我们在做我们的播客。是的。我们在做这件事。
Yeah, so she won her first Nobel Prize with her husband. And also, I don't know if I'm going to pronounce this name correctly, Henri Beccarell. They discovered radium. I mean, this is kind of cool. But did you know this? This is romantic. She was not originally included in the award. Pierre, her husband, had to write a letter to make sure she got credit for her portion.
是的，所以她和她的丈夫一起赢得了她的第一个诺贝尔奖。而且，我不知道我是不是能正确地发音这个名字，亨利·贝克勒尔。他们发现了镭。我的意思是，这挺酷的。但你知道这个吗？这很浪漫。她最初并未被列入获奖名单。皮埃尔，她的丈夫，不得不写信确保她因为她那部分的
of the research and that she was named on the Nobel Prize. He stood up for her. Way to go, Pierre. I know. They worked side by side all the time. And very often she was left out of recognitions. And there were a couple times when Pierre refused to accept a recognition because they wouldn't include his wife's name on it. And he was like, no, I won't come get your award. That's a good man right there. I know. Unfortunately, Pierre slipped and fell under the wheels of a horse carriage, and he died at the age of 46. Oh, no. I know. She was widowed very early. After his death, she won her second Nobel Prize in Chemistry. And then she died very young at the age of 66. They believe as a result of all of the radiation poisoning from all her research. Did you know that
研究而获得荣誉，并确保她在诺贝尔奖上被提名。他为她挺身而出。做得好，皮埃尔。我知道。他们一直并肩工作。而且她经常被排除在表彰之外。有好几次，皮埃尔拒绝接受表彰，因为他们不把妻子的名字写在上面。他当时说：不，我不会来领你们的奖。那绝对是个好男人。我知道。不幸的是，皮埃尔滑倒并摔在了马车的车轮下，他在46岁时去世了。哦，不。我知道。她很早就守寡了。在他去世后，她赢得了她的第二个诺贝尔奖，是化学奖。然后她在66岁时很年轻就去世了。他们认为这是因为她所有的研究带来的所有辐射中毒。你知道吗
her tomb, like where you can view her body is, I think, how do I word this? Her tomb is wrapped in one-inch led because her remains are still so radioactive that, like, people that view her body. Yes, I read that. Yeah. And also, her papers are considered, like, too dangerous to handle. Yeah. And so you have to, like, wear protective clothing. Yes.
她的坟墓，就像你可以瞻仰她的遗体的地方，我想，我该怎么说呢？她的坟墓包裹在一英寸厚的铅里，因为她的遗体仍然具有很高的放射性，以至于瞻仰她遗体的人们……是的，我读到过。是的。而且，她的文件被认为太危险而无法触碰。是的。所以你必须穿防护服。是的。
But here are some quotes that they said about each other. Okay. Marie said, My husband and I were so closely united by our affection and our common work that we passed nearly all of our time together. He was a generous, gentle soul whose love and support made all my work possible. And then in a letter that Pierre wrote to Marie, he said, It would be a fine thing if we could spend our lives near each other, hypnotized by our dreams.
但以下是他们对彼此说过的一些名言。好的。玛丽说：我和丈夫因我们的深情和共同的工作而紧密相连，我们几乎把所有的时间都花在了一个大写的一起。他是一个慷慨、温柔的灵魂，他的爱和支持使我所有的工作成为可能。然后在一封皮埃尔写给玛丽的信中，他说：如果我们能彼此靠近地度过一生，被我们的梦想催眠，那将是一件美好的事。
Oh my gosh, that's so lovely. I know, I know. You know, maybe it's just because Lee and I are both artists and we so often work together. I love when a couple shares a passion like that. And then they make it so that the other person can live out their dreams. It's so beautiful. It is. I'm going to share that with Josh, although he's probably listening right now because he listens to our episode every week.
哦，天哪，太美了。我知道，我知道。你知道，也许这只是因为我和李都是艺术家，我们经常一起工作。我喜欢当一对情侣分享这样的激情时。然后他们让对方能够实现自己的梦想。太美了。确实如此。我要把这个分享给乔什，尽管他可能现在正在听，因为他每周都听我们的节目。
Hi, Josh. Hi, Josh, babe. That's like me and you in the kitchen. It is. Oh, Jen, I love that. Well, you know, we also asked you all to send in your office romance stories and you really showed up for us. You sent in so many great moments. Let's start with Renee Kay in Jupiter, Florida, who wrote in and said,
嗨，乔什。嗨，乔什，宝贝。那就像我和你在厨房里一样。是的。哦，珍娜，我太喜欢了。好吧，你知道的，我们也请你们所有人发送你们的办公室恋情故事，你们真的太给力了。你们发来了那么多美好的时刻。让我们从佛罗里达州朱庇特的雷妮·K开始，她写信说：
My now husband and I used to work at the same company, and we met at an after-work happy hour. After we were introduced, he walked away to mingle with other people, but I kept noticing him watching me. It was like how Ryan noticed Jim staring at him when he was at reception. Then at work meetings, we used to catch each other's eye across the room. My husband would pretend to be shocked to find me looking at him, and then he would hide behind his papers. Now we've been together for seven years. Sometimes you find true love in a mundane workplace. Don't worry, kids.
我现在的老公以前和我们在同一家公司工作，我们在下班后的欢乐时光认识的。我们经介绍认识后，他走开去和其他人交往，但我一直注意到他在看着我。就像瑞安注意到吉姆在前台时盯着他看一样。然后在工作会议上，我们经常隔着房间对视。我老公会假装很惊讶地发现我在看他，然后他会躲在文件后面。现在我们已经在一起七年了。有时你在平凡的工作场所也能找到真爱。别担心，孩子们。
You'll find the Dwight to your Angela. Aw. Isn't that cute? That is so sweet. I know. Okay, I grabbed one, and this is from Rachel M. in Los Angeles. Okay. Rachel said, in 2008, I started my first job in an office and my boyfriend of four years
你们会找到属于你们的德怀特，属于你们的安吉拉。啊。是不是很可爱？太甜了。我知道。好的，我挑了一个，这是洛杉矶的瑞秋·M发来的。好的。瑞秋说：2008年，我开始了我在办公室的第一份工作，我谈了四年却
that wouldn't take our relationship to the next step also worked there but in the warehouse. What? So Rachel worked in the office and her boyfriend of four years worked in the warehouse. Listen to this. A few months in, I met a guy at the office and immediately fell for him but couldn't say anything since I was dating someone. We were friends and went to lunch and talked every day, but I didn't have the guts to jump ship since it was so uncertain when I had something comfortable, and I had no idea if the new guy liked me. Rachel said, The Office seasons 1 through 3 were super influential to me because I resonated so much with Pam.
不愿把我们的关系推进到下一步的男友也在那里工作，但他在仓库里。什么？所以瑞秋在办公室工作，她谈了四年的男友在仓库工作。听听这个。几个月后，我在办公室遇到一个男生，立刻就爱上了他，但由于我正和别人交往，什么也说不出口。我们是朋友，每天一起吃午餐聊天，但我没有勇气跳槽，因为一切都太不确定了，而我当时的生活挺舒适的，我也根本不知道那个新男生是否喜欢我。瑞秋说：《办公室》第一到第三季对我的影响超级大，因为我和帕姆产生了强烈的共鸣。
I mean, yes, Rachel, I can see why. You're living parallel lives. Truly. Rachel said, when Pam leaves Roy for Jim, another guy at the time. the office, and it turns out amazing. It gave me the courage to jump and choose the uncertain instead of staying comfortable and unhappy. I chose the other guy, and now we've been together 17 years, married and have a son. Thanks for giving me the courage to get what I want and never settle. The final monologue of Pam at the series finale makes me cry every time I see it since I
我的意思是，是的，瑞秋，我能理解为什么。你们过着平行的人生。真的。瑞秋说：当帕姆为了吉姆——办公室里的另一个男生——离开罗伊，结果证明一切太棒了。它给了我勇气去跃迁，选择不确定性，而不是停留在舒适却不快乐的状态。我选择了另一个男生，现在我们已经在一起17年了，结婚了并有一个儿子。谢谢你们给了我勇气去追求我想要的，绝不将就。每当我看到《办公室》大结局时帕姆的最后独白，我都会落泪，因为我
felt like it was exactly for someone like me who conquered my fears and got what I wanted since life just isn't that long. That is so wonderful. And again, look at that monologue that Pam had, that writing. I am just amazed as we're reviewing all of these scenes, just how our writers continue to touch people's lives by their amazing work. Well, that's good art, right? Yeah. That's good theater. That's good TV, good movies. You hear something spoken or reflected back to you and it transforms you. Yeah. And that's such good writing. Yeah. Absolutely. All right. We have another letter to share with you. This was an office-inspired romance as well. It's from Anna C, from Brazil, but now living in Belgium. She just wanted us to know that. I always love when
觉得它完全是为像我这样战胜了恐惧并得到想要的东西的人准备的，因为生命确实没有那么长。太棒了。而且，再看看帕姆的那段独白，那个剧本。每当回顾所有这些场景时，我都由衷地感到惊讶，我们的编剧们是如何通过他们惊人的作品继续触动人们的生活的。好吧，那是好艺术，对吧？是的。那是好戏剧。那是好电视，好电影。你听到有人说出的话或映照出你的内心，然后你被改变了。是的。这就是如此棒的剧本。是的。绝对的。好吧。我们还有一封信要分享给你们。这也是一段受办公室启发的恋情。来自安娜·C，她来自巴西，但现在住在比利时。她只是想让我们知道这一点。我总是喜欢
people give us those caveats. I love it. I want to know. I want to know. Anna said, the office didn't just make me laugh. It led me to the love of my life. In 2012, I threw myself a the office-themed birthday party. I even made a stapler in Jello like Jim's prank on Dwight. And one day I posted a photo on Reddit. And that's how I met my husband. He's from Belgium and we connected through the posts. Now we're married for two years.
人们给我们这些附加说明。我喜欢。我想知道。我想知道。安娜说：《办公室》不仅让我开怀大笑，它还把我带到了我一生的挚爱身边。2012年，我为自己办了一场《办公室》主题的生日派对。我甚至做了一个果冻里的订书机，就像吉姆对德怀特的恶作剧那样。有一天，我在Reddit上发了一张照片。这就是我和我老公相遇的经历。他是比利时人，我们通过帖子联系上了。现在我们结婚两年了。
And now I live in Belgium in a little rural town. And I'm learning Dutch. Your podcast keeps me company eight hours a day while I work. It's my daily joy. After we got married, we even flew back to Brazil just to bring my dog Frida to Belgium. Now she lives here with us with our Mel Bingle Cat Nova. We live in the countryside in a house surrounded by our little farm where we grow potatoes, onions, carrots, lettuce, broccoli, cauliflower, strawberries, raspberries, cherries, apples, pears, grapes, eggplants, peppers, peppers,
现在我住在比利时的一个乡村小镇。我在学荷兰语。你们的播客在我工作的八小时里陪伴着我。这是我每天的快乐。结婚后，我们甚至飞回巴西，只为了把我的狗狗弗里达带到比利时。现在她和我们的猫诺娃一起住在这里。我们住在乡村的一所房子里，周围是我们的小农场，我们在那里种植土豆、洋葱、胡萝卜、生菜、西兰花、花椰菜、草莓、树莓、樱桃、苹果、梨、葡萄、茄子、辣椒、辣椒，
and, and of course, beats Anna. This is such, like, the most charming life. And they met because she threw herself an office-themed party and posted about it. I want to, like, put a big circle around that because like she took the initiative to celebrate herself yes and have this like very elaborate themed party i absolutely just love that about her and then it led to love yeah she put her true self out there yeah and she found someone who loved it and responded and now they have this life i just think that's wonderful they're animals and they're growing all their food and oh i loved it well listen why don't we go to break And when we come back, we're going to read more of your letters, and we are going to discuss some meat cutts, which is an essential part of a romance.
还有，还有，当然还有甜菜。安娜。这简直是，最迷人的生活了。他们相遇是因为她为自己办了一场《办公室》主题的派对并把它发到了网上。我想，给这个加上一个大大的圆圈，因为她采取了主动去庆祝自己，是的，并办了这样一场精心布置的主题派对，我绝对太喜欢她这一点了，然后它引领走向了爱。是的，她展现了真实的自我，是的，她找到了一个爱它并做出回应的人，现在他们有了这样的生活，我只是觉得这太美妙了。他们有动物，他们自己种所有的食物，哦，我太喜欢了。好吧，听着，我们为什么不去休息一下？
It really is one of my favorite parts to break down, as we know. Yes. And you even shared about it on our podcast, the origin of it. We'll revisit that. And guess what? What? We have our very own Kelly Kapoor's Meet Cute. We'll be back.
当我们回来时，我们将阅读更多你们的信件，并且我们将讨论一些浪漫邂逅，这是浪漫中必不可少的一部分。这确实是我最喜欢剖析的部分之一，正如我们所知。是的。而且你甚至在我们的播客中分享过它的起源。我们会重温这一点。而且你猜怎么着？什么？我们有我们自己的凯利·卡普尔式的浪漫邂逅。我们马上回来。
All right, we are back. Let's get into some meat cutts. Jenna, you researched the origin of the meat cute in the episode training day. Yeah, and you did a really good job. It goes all the way back to like 1938 to ye oldie movie, Bluebeard's eighth life. Anyway, there's a great meat cute there. It's over some pajamas. Jenna talks about it. But I loved it. Well, you know, the term meat cute is actually spoke. on the office. Yes, by Kelly in Training Day, which is what led me on my deep dive. Which was what led you on your deep dive. I know we've talked about it before, but I just love this scene. To me, this is Mindy, just having fun. Truly, this is not even work. She's just having fun. So the scene
好的，我们回来了。让我们进入浪漫邂逅。珍娜，你在《训练日》那一集里研究了浪漫邂逅的起源。是的，你做得真的很棒。它一直追溯到1938年的一部老电影《蓝胡子的第八个妻子》。不管怎样，那里有一个很棒的浪漫邂逅。那是关于睡衣的。珍娜谈到了这一点。但我很喜欢。好吧，你知道，“浪漫邂逅”这个词实际上在《办公室》里被说出来了。是的，在《训练日》中由凯利说出，这也是引导我深入研究的原因。这也是引导你深入研究的原因。我知道我们以前讨论过它，但我就是喜欢这一幕。对我来说，这就是明迪在自娱自乐。真的，这甚至不是工作。她只是在找乐子。所以那一幕是
is it's DeAngelo Vickers' first day. Kelly has put on a super cute, very stylish, like work business suit. It's got like a blue jacket with like a blue skirt. She's got these black like rimmed glasses. She doesn't wear glasses. It's just a prop. It's a total prop. And her plan is to catch DeAngelo's eye by dropping all these files and folders on the ground. And he's going to help her scoop them up. And his reaction is really funny. Let's hear it. I'll get that. You guys. Don't let's just, you know. It's just, you know. Hi. Hello.
德安杰洛·维克斯的第一天。凯利穿了一套超级可爱、非常时尚的工作商务套装。里面有一件带蓝色裙子的蓝色夹克。她戴着一副黑框眼镜。她平时不戴眼镜。这纯粹是个道具。这完全是个道具。她的计划是通过把所有这些文件和文件夹掉在地上来吸引德安杰洛的注意。然后他会帮她把它们捡起来。而他的反应真的很好笑。让我们听听。我来拿那个。各位。别让……我们只是，你知道的。这只是，你知道的。嗨。你好。
Hi. Have we met before? No, not officially. I saw you coming out of the bathroom earlier. Well, I guess I'm going to go back to my cave. Okay. It's really great meeting you. And that is what they call a meet cute.
嗨。我们以前见过吗？不，不算正式见过。我刚才看到你从洗手间出来。好吧，我想我要回我的洞穴去了。好的。很高兴见到你。这就是他们所说的浪漫邂逅。
It's so funny. It's so funny to me, too, how DeAngelo is so clueless. Like, is this what happens, you guys? Like, do we think up these moments and then the other person? is just oblivious? Like, are meat cutes? Like, do they really happen in real time for each other? Or is it one person realizing and then the other person realizes it another time? Like, do they actually happen at the same time? I think it depends. I do. Yeah. I think there's some couples where one person like gets hit with Cupid's arrow first. Yeah. And then other times it happens at the same
太好笑了。对我来说，德安杰洛是如此一无所知，这也太好笑了。就像，大家是这样的吗？就像，是我们想出这些时刻然后另一个人只是茫然不知吗？就像，浪漫邂逅真的会实时发生在彼此身上吗？还是一个人意识到了，然后另一个人在另一个时间意识到？就像，它们真的会同时发生吗？我觉得这得看情况。确实。是的。我觉得有些情侣，其中一个人先被丘比特之箭射中。是的。然后其他时候它同时发生
time. Yeah. Because DeAngelo's answer is so honest. He's like, well, I saw you come out of the bathroom. But also, if it doesn't become a romance, is it a meat cute? That's true, you know? No, it's not a meat cute if the romance doesn't follow. I also don't think it's a meat cute if you manufacture it. Yeah, I'm not sure it counts, but I'll let other people debate that. Yeah. You know, and we never see the Jim Pam or the Dwight Angela meet cute. We actually got a letter about it. Jose V from Nutley, New Jersey said, In previous episodes, Jenna has explained how she created lore for Pam explaining how she got together with Roy and why it was so difficult from Pam's perspective to leave him. My question is for Angela.
时间。是的。因为迪安吉罗的回答太诚实了。他说，嗯，我看见你从洗手间出来了。但话说回来，如果这没有发展成浪漫关系，这还算浪漫邂逅吗？确实如此，你知道吗？不，如果接下来没有发生浪漫的故事，那就不能算浪漫邂逅。而且我认为如果是人为制造的，那也不算浪漫邂逅。是的，我不确定这算不算，但我会让其他人去争论这一点。是的。你知道的，我们从来没见过吉姆和帕姆或者德怀特和安吉拉的浪漫邂逅。我们其实收到了一封关于这事的信。来自新泽西州纳特利的何塞·V（Jose V）说：“在之前的剧集中，珍娜解释了她是如何为帕姆构思背景故事的，解释了她是如何和罗伊在一起的，以及从帕姆的角度来看，离开他是多么困难。我的问题是针对安吉拉的。”
Did she ever come up with Laura explaining how Dwight courted her? We all know they're together by the time Jim has his barbecue, but how did Dwight first approach Angela and what was that like? Oh, that's such a fun question. Well, you know, I sort of always thought somehow them both wanting to be the safety officer was what brought them together. That was the backstory I gave myself. You know, you have that moment where she goes to grab the first aid kit. And Dwight wants to take over and she's like, I'm the safety officer, not you.
她有没有想过一个背景故事来解释德怀特是如何追求她的？我们都知道在吉姆办烧烤派对时他们就已经在一起了，但德怀特最初是怎么接近安吉拉的？那是什么样的？哦，这真是个有趣的问题。嗯，你知道，我一直觉得某种程度上是他们俩都想当安全员这件事把他们撮合在了一起。那是我给自己设定的背景故事。你知道的，就是她去拿急救箱的那一刻。德怀特想接管，然后她说，我是安全员，不是你。
Remember that whole scene? Yes, of course. And that's the first time they really speak to one another in the whole series. oh my gosh did they like get in a private argument that just then led to like a big makeout session was it just like a passionate like we never saw it on camera but like they got you know they got after each other about who was the safety officer and then it just ended up with it just a roll in the hay how did that's like where my mind is gone that is so funny that is your dwight natural meet cute it all starts with a fight i sort of saw them as having to take some class together that you know
还记得整场戏吗？是的，当然。那是他们在整部剧里第一次真正跟对方说话。哦，天哪，他们是不是私下里吵了一架，然后就直接发展成了一场激吻？是不是就像那种充满激情、虽然我们在镜头里没看到，但他们俩就——你知道的——为了谁才是安全员争执了一番，最后就滚到草堆里去了？我的脑洞都开到那儿去了。太搞笑了，这就是你版本的德怀特和安吉拉的浪漫邂逅。一切都始于争吵。我以前觉得他们是一起去上了某种课，你知道……
know, I always thought this is really nerdy, okay, but this is what I thought. I could sort of see Michael being like, hey, we need a safety officer. Toby says we need a safety officer. I need someone to volunteer. And Dwight and Angela are the only two people that like sign up. Okay. And then they have to go through this, you know, sort of like the whole, you know, training little workshop together. And neither of them want to relinquish the role. So maybe there is this like like very sort of competitiveness. But yeah, that's where I saw them their first spark starting somewhere in this safety officer journey. I love it so much. I love thinking about them in safety officer train, just the two of them. Yes. And then at the end of the training, the teacher is like,
你知道，我一直觉得这挺书呆子气的，好吧，但我是这么想的。我能想象迈克尔说，嘿，我们需要一个安全员。托比说我们需要一个安全员。我需要有人自愿报名。然后德怀特和安吉拉是仅有的两个报名的人。好吧。接着他们不得不一起经历这个，你知道的，就好像整个那种，你知道的，培训小工作坊。而且他们两个谁都不想放弃这个角色。所以也许这里面有一种，非常强烈的竞争意识。但是，是的，这就是我看到他们的最初火花在安全员这段旅程中的某个地方点燃的地方。我太喜欢了。我一想到他们在安全员培训里就只有他俩，就觉得好可爱。对的。然后培训结束时，老师说：
I pick Angela. Dwight's furious. But yeah, I don't know. I think that's kind of like where it all began for them. And it's how perfect is it that it's safety officer like school? Well, you know, in addition to sort of those meet cute moments, there are so many on the office that we actually get to see. Yeah. Yeah, I love Erin and Pete. Oh, yeah. I really like them. I mean, I know they don't end up together, but I like their arc. And, you know, sometimes a romance isn't supposed to be forever, but like you grow from it and it feeds your life. And so it's still, positive. That's how I feel about Aaron and Pete's romance. I feel like it started really in that Roy's wedding episode because back at the office, that's the episode where like Clark is being the
我选安吉拉。德怀特气坏了。不过，好吧，我不知道，我觉得这有点像是他们一切开始的地方。而且，安全员这种像是学校一样的东西，是多么完美啊！好吧，你知道，除了那些浪漫邂逅的时刻之外，《办公室》里还有很多我们实际上能看到的。对的。对的，我喜欢艾琳和皮特。哦，对。我真的很喜欢他们。我的意思是，我知道他们最后没有在一起，但我喜欢他们的成长轨迹。而且，你知道的，有时候一段恋情并不一定是永远的，但你会从中成长，它会滋养你的生活。所以它仍然是积极的。这就是我对艾琳和皮特恋情的看法。我觉得它真正开始于罗伊的婚礼那一集，因为回到办公室后，那一集里克拉克就像个……
creeper and he's trying to hit on Aaron and get her that job in the news. Faky job. Like it's never going to happen for her to audition to be like a news anchor or something. Yes. And Pete like clocks it and then he becomes very protective. He even like makes it so that he's at the apartment. And then they get the hamburger afterwards. It's so sweet. Yeah. It's so sweet because he's just wanting to take care of her. And Andy's like, you know, she's hungry.
猥琐男，他试图搭讪艾琳，给她找那个新闻工作。假工作。就好像她去试镜当新闻主播什么的这种事根本不可能发生一样。是的。然后皮特注意到了，接着他就变得非常保护她。他甚至还特地出现在公寓。然后他们在那之后去吃了汉堡。太甜了。对的，太甜了，因为他就是想照顾她。安迪还说，你知道的，她饿了。
And Andy's like, take her to get a burger. And then there's that spy shot of them. Yeah. And they're clearly having the best time. I know. And after Aaron's just like trail of horrible romances, it just made me so happy. Yeah. I really want them to make it.
安迪说，带她去买个汉堡。然后还有一张他们俩的偷拍照。对的。他们显然玩得超开心。我懂。在经历了艾琳那一长串糟糕的恋情之后，这真的让我太开心了。对的，我真的很希望他们能成。
Well, we've been told they do not. I know, but I'm sorry. I know. Well, I don't think we can do a Meet Cute episode and not play Michael and Holly's Meet Cute. It's so good. So good. It's in Goodbye Toby. It's just the best. Okay, so I pulled two clips. The first one is the very first time they meet. And the second one is pretty much right after that because Michael is smitten pretty quickly. And Jim is like, dude, play it cool. Play it cool. I love Michael. in that scene with him so much. He's like, I love her. I love her. And then, anyway, he goes back in the annex looking for her and they have this conversation while she's trying to fix her desk chair. Yeah. Hey, Michael. Oh, hey, do you still work here? I'd like to introduce you to my replacement. Nah. Come on. No, I think I will pass. Michael Scott. This is Holly. Hi. Hi. Hi. Yeah, right. Okay. Well, they hired a female Toby. Good for the world. Thank you, God, for creating two of you.
嗯，我们都被告知他们没有成。我知道，但不好意思。我知道。好吧，我觉得我们不能做一期“浪漫邂逅”主题的节目却不播放迈克尔和霍莉的浪漫邂逅。太棒了。太棒了。它在《再见托比》那一集里。简直棒极了。好吧，所以我挑了两个片段。第一个片段是他们第一次见面。第二个片段几乎就在那之后不久，因为迈克尔很快就坠入爱河了。吉姆在一旁说，老兄，淡定点。淡定点。我超爱那一幕里的迈克尔。他当时就像，我爱她。我爱她。然后，总之，他又回到附楼去找她，当她试图修理办公椅时，他们展开了这段对话。对的。嘿，迈克尔。哦，嘿，你还在这儿工作吗？我想把我的接班人介绍给你。才不要。少来。不，我想我还是算了吧。迈克尔·斯科特。这是霍莉。嗨。嗨。嗨。好吧，好吧。好吧，他们雇了一个女托比。感谢上帝创造了两个你。
Here's how things work here. My job is to make the office fun. Your job is to make the office lame. And we have an eternal struggle, you and I. And only one of us can be the winner. Spoiler alert. I'm going to win. Man, someone doesn't like HR.
这里的事情是这样的。我的工作是让办公室变得有趣。你的工作是让办公室变得无聊。我们之间有一场永恒的斗争，你和我。而且我们当中只能有一个赢家。剧透一下。我会赢的。天哪，有人不喜欢人力资源部。
Yeah. What did you do, do you do, him? Nothing. No, he tortured me with his awfulness. Yeah, I know what you mean. I nearly fell asleep when he gave me a tour of the files. Well, look, I'll let you get back to work, but I really look forward to working with you, Mr. Scott.
对啊。你对他做了什么？什么也没做。没，他用他的糟糕透顶折磨我。对，我懂你的意思。当他带我参观文件档案时，我差点睡着。好吧，听着，我让你回去工作，但我真的很期待和你一起工作，斯科特先生。
Michael. He can't even get his name out. He's so flabbergasted because the fact that she's, like, agreeing with him that Toby is boring, he's like, you are my soul mate. Yes. And now is when Jim's like, play it cool. And he goes back to the Anna. Let's hear that part.
迈克尔。他连自己的名字都说不出口了。他太震惊了，因为她竟然同意他关于托比很无聊的看法，他当时心想，你就是我的灵魂伴侣。是的。然后这时候吉姆就说，淡定点。接着他又回到了附楼。让我们听听那部分。
That's how we buy them, actually. I'm trying to adjust the lumbar support on Toby's chair, and that made this up-down lever thing not work, and then I took the whole chair apart, and that is the story of me on the floor. It's pretty good, right? I'm going to sell the movie rights. And the sequel, Woman Stans at Descan works.
我们买的时候其实就是这样的。我正想调整托比椅子上的腰部支撑，结果这让那个上下调节的杠杆不管用了，然后我把整把椅子都拆了，这就是我趴在地上的故事。挺搞笑的吧？我打算把电影版权卖了。还有续集《女人站在坏掉的办公桌旁》。
So, I have no idea how you... How you sit like that? Yoga. Sit on floor and put together a chair we will. Yo, duh. Um. Pass curvy metal piece, you will. So are you in town this weekend?
所以，我不知道你是怎么……你是怎么那样坐的？瑜伽。坐在地上拼椅子，你会的。噢，对。嗯。递过弯曲的金属件，你会的。那你这周末在镇上吗？
Because I'm not, I'm not, I'm not going to be in town. Going out of town. Oh, so you can't make my orgy? Kidding. Kidding. Acting! Acting! Acting!
因为我不在，我不在，我这周末不在镇上。要离开小镇。哦，所以你不能去我的性爱派对咯？开玩笑。开玩笑。演技！演技！演技！
Love it. Yeah. Oh my God. I don't know why. It, like, actually gives me chills listening to them. They could not be more perfect for each other. The look on Michael's face when she returns his Yoda impression, I mean, he can't, he literally does like a gasp. He's like, and then that she makes an orgy joke. He's crawling out of his skin. He can't believe this is happening. They're so perfect for each other. All right. Well, I asked everyone in
太棒了。是的。哦，天哪。我不知道为什么，听着他们说话，我甚至真的起鸡皮疙瘩了。他们俩简直是天造地设的一对。当霍莉模仿尤达时，迈克尔脸上的表情，我的意思是，他甚至倒吸了一口凉气。他当时就像，接着她还开了一个性爱派对的玩笑。他简直兴奋得快要跳出自己的皮囊了。他简直不敢相信这一切正在发生。他们太般配了。好了。嗯，我让……
the office ladies group to pull a clip from their favorite meat cute in a movie. Because guys, I love meet cutes and I wanted to hear them. So where should we start? This was so fun, actually, because it gave us, I don't know about you guys, but to me, I got to revisit so many favorite moments of mine in movies. Yeah. I mean, it just puts you in a good mood. It does.
办公室辣妈群里的每个人都从她们最喜欢的电影浪漫邂逅中挑一个片段。因为伙计们，我超爱浪漫邂逅，而且我很想听听大家的分享。那我们从哪里开始呢？其实这真的很有趣，因为它让我们——不知道你们怎么样，但对我来说——重温了许多我最喜欢的电影桥段。是的。我的意思是，这真的能让你有个好心情。确实如此。
Sam, do you want to go first? Sure. mine is from my all-time favorite movie The Princess Bride I love that movie Our favorite pastimes were riding her horse And tormenting the farm boy that worked there His name was Wesley
萨姆，你想先来吗？好啊。我的片段来自我最喜欢的电影《公主新娘》。我超级喜欢那部电影。我们最喜欢的消遣是骑着她的马，还有捉弄在那里干农活的农夫男孩。他的名字叫韦斯利。
But she never called him that Isn't that a wonderful beginning Yeah, it's really good Nothing gave buttercup As much pleasure as ordering Wesley around Farm boy Polish, polish my horse to saddle I want to see my face shining in it by morning
但她从来不叫他这个名字 难道这不是一个美好的开端吗 是的，真的很棒 没有什么能比使唤韦斯利更能让毛茛花感到快乐的了 农夫男孩 把我的马鞍擦亮，擦亮 让我能在明天早晨看到自己的脸倒映在上面
As you wish As you wish was all he ever said I just think it's just so sweet It just gets me to tears every time I know And then eventually we find out that as you wish means I love you As you wish
遵命 这就是他永远只会说的话 我只是觉得这太甜蜜了 每次都让我感动得落泪 我懂的 最后我们发现“遵命”的意思其实就是“我爱你” 遵命
The part where she goes rolling down after him kills me to it. Yeah. Yeah. All right, Cassie. Mine is from the holiday. It's when Kate Winslet and Jack Black meet. I just love the premise of that movie of like switching houses and then they both fall in love. It's such a cool movie and that relationship in particular is just so cool and fun. And John Krasinski's in that movie. But he is? Yeah, he's Cameron Diaz's assistant. He's like an assistant like editor. Editor when it's like he's only in like you know, at the beginning. But yeah, that's kind of a little office crossover. But I love that movie, too. Do you have your clip? Yeah.
她追着他一路滚下去的那场戏简直把我笑死了。对的。对的。好了，卡西。我的片段来自《恋爱假期》。就是卡茨·温丝莱特和杰克·布莱克相遇的那段。我太喜欢那部电影的设定了，就是互换房子，然后他们两个坠入爱河。这是一部太酷的电影了，尤其是那段关系，简直又酷又有趣。而且乔恩·卡拉辛斯基也出演了那部电影。真的吗？对啊，他是卡梅隆·迪亚兹的助手。他好像是个助理剪辑师。剪辑师，虽然他只出现了——你知道的，就在开头。不过，对啊，那算是一个小小的办公室联动吧。但我也很喜欢那部电影。你带剪辑片段了吗？对。
Hi. I'm so sorry. I'm new at the gate thing. It's okay. It was pretty funny. I'm Miles. I work with Ethan. Ethan? Amanda's ex. Oh, right. Right. Do you know when she'll be back? I'm supposed to pick up a couple things. Amanda's in England, actually, on holiday. I'm staying here for a few weeks where She's away. Oh. Uh-oh. You okay?
嗨。真的很抱歉。我对弄这个大门不太在行。没关系。挺搞笑的。我是迈尔斯。我和伊桑一起工作。伊桑？阿曼达的前男友。哦，对。对。你知道她什么时候回来吗？我得来拿几样东西。阿曼达其实在英国度假。我在这里借住几个星期，在她离开的这段时间。哦。噢。你没事吧？
Yes. Somebody just blew into my eye. Oh, I hate that. Let me see. Yep. You got something in your eyelash. You want me to get it? Um, okay.
没事。刚才有什么东西吹进我眼里了。哦，我讨厌那样。我看看。行了。你睫毛上有个东西。要我帮你弄出来吗？嗯，好吧。
Okay. Yeah, Santa Ana's. Pardon? The wind. It's what makes it so warm this time you. Legend has it. When the Santa Ana's blow, all bets are off. Anything can happen.
好吧。圣安娜风。 啥？ 风。就是这风让这时的天气这么暖和。传说中当圣安娜风刮起时，一切皆有可能。什么都会发生。
That's it. You okay? better it's pretty stupid i have never heard of this santa anna wins like legend has it but i know but it's also like such a perfect l-a cute that like the santa anas are part of what brings them together and he like blows in her eye right or something like that holds like an eyelash out of her eye very gently yeah that's so cute i love it all right jenna should i go next yeah what's yours Angela? Well, you know, there's so many, so many moments. I love a meet cute. I love a rom-com. It was really hard for me to choose. But one that always cracks me up. And I think the chemistry in the
好了。没事了吧？好多了。挺蠢的，我以前从来没听说过这种圣安娜风的传说，但我知道，但这也太像那种完美的洛杉矶式浪漫邂逅了，圣安娜风居然成了他们俩产生交集的一部分，而且他还对着她的眼晴吹气，对吧，或者是类似的事情，非常温柔地把她眼睫毛拿出来，对，太可爱了，我很喜欢。好了，珍娜，我是不是该接着说了？好啊，安吉拉，你的呢？嗯，你知道的，有太多太多的时刻了。我超爱浪漫邂逅。我超爱浪漫喜剧。我真的很难抉择。但有一个桥段总是让我捧腹大笑。而且我认为那场戏里的化学反应太棒了。来自《疯狂愚蠢的爱》。就是瑞恩·高斯林的角色的那种超级油滑的家伙。他去搭讪艾玛·斯通。而她当时的反应是：你谁啊？这什么情况？他们有一段非常搞笑的对话。而且她的好朋友全程都在桌边。所以我其实也很喜欢这个设定。我们来听听看。明明有那么大潜力，你却偏偏在幻想把红发丑男柯南·奥布莱恩搞到手。他挺搞笑的。看起来就像根胡萝卜，亲爱的。看起来就像根胡萝卜。嗨。看起来就像根胡萝卜。柯南·奥布莱恩。我朋友汉娜觉得他很性感。真奇怪，因为我觉得你的朋友汉娜才真的性感。
scene is so great. It's from crazy, stupid love. And it's when, you know, Ryan Gosling's character is this real slick guy. And he's going to hit on Emma Stone. And she's just like, who are you? What is happening? And they have this very funny exchange. And her, her, like, best friend is like at the table the whole time. So I sort of love that component too. Let's hear it. So much potential and you've resorted to fantasizing about Conan Ginger Junk O'Brien. He is funny. It looks like a carrot, honey. It looks like a carrot. Hi. It looks like a carrot. Conan O'Brien. My friend Hannah here thinks he's sexy. That's weird because I think that Your friend Hannah is really sexy.
天哪。你刚才竟然说出这种话。你多大了？你是干嘛的，律师吗？我太喜欢了。少来。我懂的。你上钩了吗？
Oh, my God. You did not just say that. How old are you? What are you, lawyer? I love it. Come on. I know. You on?
她上钩了吗？把我迷住了。你不觉得自己年纪轻轻，却在用这种老套的搭讪台词吗？反对。诱导性提问。哇，汉娜，你穿那条裙子真好看，就好像你在给裙子面子一样？
Is she? Got to me. Don't you think you're a little old to be using cheesy pickup lines? Objection. Leading the witness. Wow, Hannah, you're really wearing that dress like you're doing it a favor?
天哪。这算是一句台词。我坐在那边过去两个小时，视线一刻也离不开你，这是一个事实。我的意思是，这个酒吧里有许多美丽的女人。包括你的朋友在内。我爱你，但我的视线离不开你。这是一个事实，这不是台词。
Oh, God. That's a line. Me sitting over there for the past two hours not being able to take my eyes off of you is a fact. I mean, there's lots of beautiful women in this bar. Your friend included. I love you, but I can't take my eyes off of you. That's a fact, it's not a line.
我觉得你非常有吸引力。你觉得我有吸引力吗？她觉得有。我没有。你觉得有？她觉得有。是的，她觉得有。我没有。你觉得有。
I find you very attractive. Do you find me attractive? She does. I don't. You do? She does. Yes, she does. I don't. You do.
我没有。汉娜，我能请你喝一杯吗？不。你经常说“不”，对吧？不。哦天哪。请求接近陪审席？说真的？
I don't. Hannah, can I buy a drink? No. You say no a lot, don't you? No. Oh boy. Permission to approach the bench? Seriously?
好了，来吧，让我发表一下结案陈词。好吧，请便。请便。汉娜，我们生活在一个物质世界里，对吧？嗯哼。而且你会变老，对吧？嗯哼。我向你保证这一点。
Just come on, let me deliver my closing argument. Yeah, proceed. proceed. Anna, we live in a physical world, right? Uh-huh. And you're going to age, right? Mm-hmm. I guarantee you this.
你绝对不会后悔跟酒吧里的一个在床上绝对是个花花公子的家伙回家过夜。但我不能保证你不会不后悔。这是个双重否定。你才是个双重否定。好吧。汉娜，你要买杯饮料吗？好吧。你知道吗？
You're never going to regret going home with a guy from the bar that one time that was a total tomcat in the sack. But I can't guarantee that you won't not regret it. It's a double negative. You're a double negative. Okay. Anna, you're going to buy a drink? Okay. You know what?
是时候回家了。真的吗？嗯哼。哇。我来叫车。T-boat免费吗？那我该叫我的车，还是你的车？要不我去把车开过来？
It's time to go home. Really? Mm-hmm. Wow. I'll do it. The T-boat saw free. So should I get my car, or yours? Can I pull the car around?
你喝酒了吗？我尽量。莉兹。来了。哦，天哪。是不是太棒了？好吧，我想问你们这个问题。萨姆、卡西、安吉拉，对我们大家来说，这招对你们管用吗？
Have you been drinking? I'll try. Liz. Coming. Oh, my gosh. Isn't that so good? Okay, let me ask you this question. Sam Cassie, Angela, to all of us, would that work on you?
你们会跟瑞恩·高斯林一起回家吗？当然会。我要跟瑞恩·高斯林回家。他就像那样走到我的桌前。我的意思是，他的演讲，就像——就像，听着，你难道会后悔这一个夜晚吗？我会觉得，不，我不会。我才不会后悔呢。
Are you heading home with Ryan Gosling? Hell yeah. I'm going home with Ryan Gosling. He walks out to my table like that. I mean, his speech, like, Like, listen, are you ever going to regret this one night? I would be like, no, I'm not. I'm not going to regret it.
我觉得我会跟他回家，然后我觉得我可能需要花好几天时间才能反应过来刚刚发生了什么。我得在脑海里重新播放一遍，才能意识到我是怎么跟他回家的。不，他连两句台词都说不完。就像，我会马上拒绝他，然后说，离我远点。卡西，我和你站一边。我和你站一边。我选“不”。我会说，抱歉，老兄。
I think I would go home with him, and I think it would take me a couple days to realize what happened. I would have to replay it in my brain to realize how I would get home with him. No, he wouldn't get two lines. Like, I would have shut him down right away to be like, get out of here. Cassie, I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm a no. I'm like, sorry, dude.
而且我认为这只对艾玛·斯通的角色管用，因为她当时正处在一个脆弱的时期。这就是那部电影有趣的地方，他们最后确实坠入了爱河。但我觉得如果是珍娜或者我的话，肯定会立刻拒绝他。但她确实拒绝了。她走了。她没有跟他离开酒吧。不。她后来又回来了。然后她说，其实，我现在想做点冲动的事。对的。你知道，太搞笑了。我有一个朋友，是个大名人。她有点像那种，你叫它什么来着，就是，随便吧。我们就是那种，稍微有点名气，就稍微有一点，对吧？等等，这个朋友是稍微有点名气。稍微有点名气。好吧。然后她当时在做一个项目，
And I only think it works with Emma Stone's character because she's. at a weak point. And that's like, I think what's fun about that movie is they do end up falling in love. But I think she wouldn't have been a Jenna and me and shut them down immediately. But she did. She left. She does not leave the bar with them. No. She is later. And she's like, actually, now I want to do something impulsive. Yeah. You know, it's so funny. I have a friend of mine who's like a famous person. And she's sort of like, what do you call it? Like, you know, whatever. We're just like, just a scooch famous, just a scooch, right? Wait, this friend is a scooch famous. A scooch famous. Okay. And she was working on a project and
里面有一个领衔主演的人，超级出名，也超级性感。然后他有点搭讪她，她当时就想，太棒了，走吧。然后她讲述他们在一起过夜的故事时说，我听进去了他说的每一句话。她让咱们这一群人都听得入迷了，而且，你知道的，我们都发誓要保密，但她当时说，我这辈子都不会后悔。她说，这简直太棒了。超出了我所有的预期。他在各方面都很厉害。而且在她讲完这个故事后特别搞笑的是，我们其中一个朋友——你知道的，当你认识一个人足够久的时候，就能说出那种非常诚实话语的朋友——就说了一句：对你来说，从这以后走的全是下坡路了。
there was someone that was like a lead person who's super famous and super hot. And he kind of hit on her and she was like, hell yeah, let's go. And she tells her story of their night together is like, I hung on every word. She had a group of us, like, riveted and, you know, we're all sworn to secrecy, but she was like, I will never regret it for the rest of my life. She was like, it was so fantastic. It exceeded all of my expectations. He was good at all the things. And it was really funny after she told this story, one of our friends who, you know, when you've known someone so long, can just say the really honest thing. She was like, it's all downhill from here for you.
就像，再也没有什么东西能比这更棒了。总之。但是，是的，我到现在，每当我在电影里看到这个人时，我都会忍不住想起这件事。对的，你就会想，他各方面真的很厉害。然后还有一件事，就是她那天晚上真的睡在那里了。她说过的一件事是，她本来没打算过夜，所以她没有带睡衣或者任何睡觉穿的东西。然后他正好有这样一个盒子。他刚刚收到了一家T恤公司的快递赞助。所以他当时就想，哦，等等。然后他去把这个盒子打开了。
Like, never, nothing will ever be as good as that again. Anyway. But yeah, I still, and now when I see this person in movies, I can't help but think about it. Yeah, you're like, he does all the things really well. And then the other thing is she actually slept there. One of the things she said was that she wasn't planning on that so she didn't have pajamas or anything to sleep in. And he just had this box. He had just gotten a delivery. He was doing a branded campaign with some t-shirt company. And so he was like, oh, wait. And he went and he opened this
然后他说，给你。然后她当时就想，而且，他对拥有这么多的周边产品感到非常印象深刻。所以我当时就想，不仅这次约会棒极了，而且她还得到了一件非常舒服的T恤。但她当时就说，这件衣服太柔软了。我穿着它回家了。总之，太搞笑了。我本来没打算分享所有这些细节的。但事情就是这样。好吧。
box. And he was like, here. And she was like, also, she was just so impressed at how much merch he had. So I was like, not only was this hookup amazing, but she got this really comfortable t-shirt. But she was like, it was so soft. And I walked, I went home with it. Anyway, it was so funny. I did not mean to share all that. But there you go. All right.
好吧，我要分享我最喜欢的浪漫邂逅片段。它来自电影《月色撩人》，这是我最喜欢的浪漫喜剧。排名在这部和《当哈利遇上萨利》之间。但《月色撩人》里的浪漫邂逅简直，哦，太棒了。所以，你知道的，雪儿饰演的角色订婚了。她和一个非常安全、踏实的男人订婚了。她以前结过婚，而她的第一任丈夫被公共汽车撞死了。所以她觉得自己在爱情里运气很不好。因此她现在打算嫁给这个非常安全的选项。但这个男人和他的弟弟有宿怨，他要飞去外地。他说，在我离开期间，你能不能去拜托我的弟弟来参加我们的婚礼，因为那会让我非常开心。所以她去找尼古拉斯·凯奇，也就是那男人的弟弟。他是个面包师。而且他整个人——我的意思是，他穿着一件汗衫，满身大汗。他正在把面包铲进一个炽热的烤箱里。而且他脾气超级暴躁。
Well, I will share my favorite meat, cute scene. It's from the movie Moonstruck, which is my favorite romantic comedy. It goes between that and when Harry met Sally. But the Meek Cute and Moonstruck is just, oh, it's so good. So, you know, Cher's character is engaged to be married. She gets engaged to a very safe, stable man. She's been married before, and her first husband got hit by a bus. So she thinks she has bad luck in love. And so she's going to now marry this really safe choice. But he has bad blood with his brother, and he's going to fly out of town. And he says, while I'm gone, will you please go down and convince him. my brother to come to our wedding because that would make me so happy. So she goes down to meet Nicholas Cage, the guy's brother. He's a baker. And he's just, I mean, he's in his like, he's sweaty in a tank top. And he's shoveling bread into a hot oven. And he's super grumpy.
然后她说，嘿，我要和你哥哥约翰结婚了。而他却说，我没有生活。我哥哥约翰尼夺走了我的生活。然后她说，我们能找个地方谈谈吗？接着他举起戴着手套的那只手，露出他的一只手其实是一个木制的假肢。然后他说出了这样一番话。你知道我怎么回事吗？没有。
And she's like, hey, I'm going to get married to your brother, John. And he's like, I have no life. My brother Johnny took my life. And she's like, can we go somewhere to talk? And then he holds up his gloved hand and he reveals that one of his hands is actually a wooden prosthetic hand. And then he says this. Do you know about me? Mm-mm.
好吧。这不怪任何人，但事情就是发生了。你看，这个世界太假了。五年前，我订过婚，然后约翰尼来到这里，他为我订购面包，我说，哦，好吧，来点面包，然后我把手放进切片机里，手被卡住了，因为我当时没有注意力集中。切片机把我的手给绞掉了。
Okay. Nothing is anybody's fault. but things happen look this word is fake five years ago I was engaged to be married and and Johnny came in here and he ordered bread for me and I said oh okay some bread and I put my hand in the slicer and it got caught because I wasn't paying attention the slicer chewed off my hand This is funny because when my fiance found out about it, but she found out that I had been named,
这挺搞笑的，因为当我未婚妻发现这件事后，她发现我变成了残疾人，她为了另一个男人抛弃了我。这就是你和约翰尼之间的宿怨吗？是的，就是这样。对，但这不是约翰尼的错。我不管。我才不是什么狗屁正义纪念碑。我失去了手。我失去了未婚妻。
she left me for another man. Is that the bad blood between you and Johnny? Yes, that's it. Yeah, but that's not Johnny's fault. I don't care. I ain't no freaking monument to justice. I lost my hand. I lost my bride.
约翰尼有他的手。约翰尼有他的未婚妻。你想让我把心碎收起来，然后忘记它？把它收起来然后忘掉？是的。这就是她想要的吗？约翰尼有他的手。约翰尼有他的未婚妻。
Johnny has his hand. Johnny has his bride. You want me to take my heartbreak, put it away and forget. Put it away and forget. Yeah. Is that what she wants? Johnny has his hand. Johnny has his bride.
好吧。所以她打算说，好了，冷静点。我要带你回你的公寓。我要给你做一份生牛排。这不是你喜欢的做法。这是你必须要吃的做法。对的。
Yeah. Okay. So she's going to be like, okay, settle down. I'm going to take you up to your apartment. I'm going to cook you a raw steak. It's not how you like it. It's how you're going to eat it. Right.
因为你是狼。对，他是狼。他是狼。他需要生牛排。他需要牛排。她说，我觉得你是一头狼。我觉得你是一头狼。你咬断了自己的手，因为你被困在了一个错误女人的陷阱里，这就是你摆脱那段关系的方式。
Because you're the wolf. Yeah, he's the wolf. He's the wolf. And he needs the raw steak. He needs the steak. She's like, I think you're a wolf. I think you're a wolf. you chewed off your own hand because you were in a trap with the wrong woman, and that's how
而他的大脑直接当机了。他心想，完全不知道该怎么应对她。他们最后甚至有了一段充满激情的恋情，但接着她说，我必须嫁给你哥哥约翰尼。我不能嫁给你，好吗？我运气不好。我不能再为了爱情结婚了。我第一次已经这么做过了。所以我必须播放这个片段。这是当她同意和他一起去歌剧院最后见他一面，然后走回家时，他又把她领回了他的公寓。这就是他对她发表的关于爱情的演讲。我爱妳。不是他们告诉妳的那种爱。我以前也不知道。但爱不会让事情变好。它会毁了一切。它会碎了妳的心。它会把事情搞得一团糟。我们，我们来这里不是为了让事情变得完美。雪花是完美的。星星是完美的。不是我们。不是我们。我们来到这里是为了毁掉我们自己，为了让我们的心碎裂，去爱错误的人，然后死掉。我的意思是，故事书里都是狗屁。我想要妳跟我上楼，进我的床。好吧，现在我必须再次把话题带回给各位。在经历雪地纽约人行道上的那番演讲之后，你们会跟他上楼并上他的床吗？会。会，会，一千次愿意。卡西。
you got yourself out of that relationship. And his mind is blown. He's like, doesn't know what to do with her. They end up just having a passionate love affair, but then she is like, I have to marry your brother, Johnny. I'm not going to marry you, okay? I had bad luck. I can't marry for love again. I did that the first time. And so I have to play this clip. This is. is when she has agreed to go to the opera with him to see him one last time, and then on the walk home, he leads her to his apartment again. And this is the speech he gives her about love. I love you. Not like they told you love is. And I didn't know this either. But love don't make things nice. It ruins everything. It breaks your heart. It makes things of
我不喜欢被人吼。不，卡西！哪怕那是充满激情的爱的吼叫，你也会说，小声点，老兄。把音量调低点。但如果有人在圣安娜风中帮你把眼睫毛从眼睛里弄出来，卡西就会变成一滩烂泥。这就是我们学到的。不过我得说，珍娜，我也很喜欢那部电影里的那句台词，当她的妈妈——妈妈是由谁扮演的来着，是奥林匹亚·杜卡基斯吗，她太棒了吧？
mess. We, we aren't here to make things perfect. The snowflakes are perfect. The stars are perfect. Not us. Not us. We are here to ruin ourselves and, and to break our hearts and love the wrong people and, and die. I mean that the storybooks are bullshit. I want you to come upstairs with me and get in my bed. Okay, so now I have to bring it to the group again. Are you going upstairs with him and getting in his bed after that speech on the snowy New York sidewalk? Yes. Yes, yes, a thousand times yes. Cassie.
太棒了。太棒了。她对她的女儿雪儿说，她问，妳爱他们吗，洛雷塔？洛雷塔说，妈，我爱死他们了。然后她妈妈说，哦，天哪，那太糟了。我懂。这台词太棒了。哦，这真的太有趣了。
I don't like to be yelled at. No, Cassie! Even if it's like passionate love yelling, you're like, tone the volume down, buddy. Bring it down. But if someone fetches an eyelash off your eye from the Santa Ana wins, Cassie is a puddle of goo. This is what we've learned. I have to say, though, I also, Jenna, from that movie, I love the line when her mom, Mom, who's played by, is it Olympia Dukakis, who's so amazing?
我超喜欢这个互动主题，珍娜。好吧，谢谢大家。我超爱浪漫故事。真的。我觉得我们今天对彼此有了很多了解。而且也了解了很多关于一个非常帅气、不知名的名人的八卦。哦，对。好吧，我发誓要保密一辈子，但她确实得到了那件T恤。好吧，我们收到了一封信，老实说都可以直接拍成电影了。太甜了。来自威斯康星州奇佩瓦福尔斯的凯莉·K（Kaylee K），信是这样的。
So good. So good. She says to her daughter, Cher, she goes, do you love them, Loretta? And Loretta goes, Ma, I love them awful. And then her mom goes, oh, God, that's too bad. I know. It's such a great line. Oh, that was really fun.
凯莉说：“我想分享我的浪漫邂逅，或者我喜欢称之为我的初吻和末吻的故事。我和我丈夫其实在幼儿园就认识了。他是我最好的朋友。我喜欢认为这是因为他喜欢拖拉机，我也很喜欢。我们甚至坐同一条公交路线，而我鼓起勇气吻了他。他当时气坏了，因为大家都在校车上看到了，他觉得尴尬极了。第二年他转去了别的学校，但这些年来我们还是经常见面，因为我们都参加了4-H俱乐部，一起去过夏营地，最后还在同一家餐厅工作。那时候，我丈夫告诉我他喜欢我，但我对没有那种感觉。在接下来的几年里，由于共同的朋友，我们还是经常在一起玩。”
I loved that prompt, Jenna. Well, thanks, guys. I love a romance. I really do. I think we learned a lot about each other. today. And a lot about a very handsome, unnamed celebrity. Oh, yeah. Well, I'm sworn to secrecy for my life, but she got the t-shirt. Well, we got a letter that could honestly be the plot of a movie. It's so sweet. It's from Kaylee Kay in Chippewa Falls, Wisconsin, and here it is.
最终，在经历了几段失败的恋情并真正重新联系上之后，他约了我出去，剩下的就是历史了。10个月后我们订婚了，一年后结婚。我们已经结婚五年半了，开始购买家庭农场，而且一个月后就要开始建房子了。我也要顺便为我丈夫美言几句。能拥有他我真的极其幸运，他真的是最好的男人。事情的发展真是妙不可言，我真的相信一切都有它的时间表。他是我的初吻，也将是我的末吻。啊，这有多甜啊？超级甜。超级，超级甜。我觉得这真的展现了时机就是一切。千真万确。我的意思是，我们已经讨论过很多次了。对的人可能会出现。但如果时机不对，那当时就不会发生。我懂。但你看宇宙是如何不断把这两个人安排进对方的世界里的。从幼儿园一直到成年。宇宙就像是在说，我们知道你们俩最后会在一起。我们只是在等你们自己想明白。为了你们俩。对的。对的。你知道，确实有不少人写信要求你和我分享我们跟各自丈夫的浪漫邂逅。我觉得如果我们分享的话会很有趣。好吧。谁先来？你先来。好吧，有趣的是，我们在讨论时机就是一切。
Kaylee says, I thought I'd share my meat cute, or what I like to call it, my first kiss and my last kiss story. My husband and I actually met in kindergarten. He was my best friend. I like to think it's because he loved tractors and I loved them as well. We even shared the same bus route and I got the courage to kiss him. He was so mad at me because he was absolutely embarrassed since everyone saw it on our school bus. The next year he switched to a different school, but we still saw each other throughout the years because we were in 4-H, went to camp together, and eventually worked at the same restaurant. At that time, my husband told me he liked me, but I didn't feel the same about him. We still spent time with each other through the next few years because of mutual friendships.
我其实在我和李坠入爱河的十到十一年前就认识他了。太疯狂了。我很早就认识他了。我们有一个共同的朋友。李有时会来参加生日派对或婚礼。你知道的，就像当你把一个朋友圈里的所有共同朋友聚集在一起时，李有时也会在。我一直觉得他是个好人，但他根本不在我的雷达范围内，而我也不在他的雷达范围内。
Eventually, after a couple of failed relationships and really reconnecting, he asked me out, and the rest is history. We were engaged 10 months later and married a year later. We've been married for five and a half years, starting to buy the family farm and starting to build a house in just a month. I'm putting a plug in for my husband also. I'm so incredibly lucky to have him and he is truly the best man. It's funny how things work out and I really believe everything has a timeline. He was my first kiss and he'll be my last. Aw, how sweet is that? Super sweet. So, so sweet. I think it really shows how timing is everything too. It's so true. I mean, we've talked about this many times. The right person can come along. But if the
然后快进到我们相遇的10年左右，当时我正打算制作一部电影，一部浪漫喜剧。正如我们所知，我超爱这种类型的。我一直在和不同的编剧开会。而李是个编剧，可以说是那种，你叫它什么来着？就像，边缘朋友。对的。
timing isn't lining up, it doesn't happen then. I know. But look at how the universe like kept putting these two in each other's world. That's from kindergarten all the way to adulthood. The universe was like, we know who you're going to be with. We're just waiting for you to figure it out. For you guys. Yeah. Yeah. You know, we did get quite a few people who wrote in asking you and I to share our meetcutes with our husbands. And I thought it would be fun if we did. Okay. Who should go first? You go first. Okay, well, it's interesting because we're talking about how timing is everything.
对啊。所以我和他开了一个提案会议，我最喜欢他的创意。简直太棒了。那个提案最终变成了电影《巨大机械人》。当我在制作那部电影、我们把它筹备起来、他在写剧本、我们来回讨论各种意见时，我们一直在讨论什么是浪漫，什么是爱情，你是怎么坠入爱河的？哦，天哪，我的意思是，这里有些人在坠入爱河时的台词，珍娜，你为什么不读一下呢？然后我会读，我会觉得，哇，哇，然后我们就坠入爱河了。我们就是这样坠入爱河的。在某种程度上，这有点像办公室恋情。
I actually met Lee, gosh, maybe 10 or 11 years before we fell in love. So wild. I knew him a very, very long time. We had a mutual friend in common. Lee would sometimes come to like birthday parties or weddings. you know, like when you gather all this sort of like mutual friends of a friend group, Lee would sometimes be there. And I always thought he was a nice guy, but he was just not on my radar and I was not on
也是的。你知道对我来说最疯狂的是什么吗？我知道这个故事，你知道的，但我直到你刚才大声说出来之前，才真正把这些联系起来，那就是你们俩基本上是在创造一段浪漫关系，并互相分享你们认为什么是爱。是的，作为一个项目。这对我来说太疯狂了。我以前居然没把这些联系在一起。太疯狂了。哇。但最搞笑的是，在我们坠入爱河之后，很明显他就是我命中注定的人，以至于我简直不敢相信我在他身边待了10年却居然没发现。我们甚至会对彼此说这样的话。我会说，等等，你当时肯定去了某某的婚礼，对吧？
his. Then fast forward like 10 years from the time we met and I was looking to produce a movie, a romantic comedy. As we know, I love them. And I was taking meetings with different writers. and Lee was a writer and was sort of this like, what would you call it? Like peripheral friend. Right.
然后他说，是的，我去了那场婚礼。我说，我对你在那场婚礼上一点印象都没有。他说，我对你在那场婚礼上一点印象都没有。哦，天哪。就像，我们甚至都没说过话。你总有一天一定要把这个故事讲给你的孩子们听。我觉得他们一定会觉得超级好笑的。好吧，我会讲给他们听的，因为这真的说明了时机就是一切。
Yeah. And so I had a pitch meeting with him and I loved his idea the best. It was just incredible. And that pitch eventually became the movie The Giant Mechanical Man. And while I was producing that movie and we were putting it together and he was writing it and we were going back and forth like on notes, we were talking about what is romance what is love how do you fall in love oh my gosh i mean here's some dialogue of people falling in love jena why don't you read it and i would read it and i would be like wow wow and we fell in love that is how we fell in love it's sort of like an office romance in a way
对吧？对的。我们只是，在很多很多很多年里都没有用那种眼光看待对方，直到我们两个都准备好了。我太喜欢这个了，因为这太真实了。我的意思是，对我跟乔什来说，你知道的，这对我来说太有趣了，因为我在认识乔什之前就认识乔什的大儿子了。所以我们的孩子在同一个学前班，而我当时在《办公室》工作，所以我上班的时间大约是早上5点半。所以我从来不能送伊莎贝尔去上学，但我可以去和她一起吃午饭。
as well yeah you know what's so wild to me is that i know this story you know but i sort of didn't really connect with until you just saying this out loud was the fact that you guys were basically creating a romance and sharing with each other what you think love is. Yes, as a project. And that is so crazy to me. I sort of did not put that together. That's so wild. Wow. But what's so funny is like after we fell in love, it was just so obvious that he was my person. that it kind of blew my mind that I had been around him for 10 years and I didn't know it. And we would even say things to each other. I would be like, now, wait, you must have been like such and such as wedding, right?
这是最棒的事情之一，我经常能够离开片场去和她一起吃午饭。我总是会在她的幼儿园故事时间到达。他们会坐在这棵大树下的一个圈里听故事。这简直是世界上最甜蜜的事情。我记得我第一次见到杰克的时候。我不记得第一次见到乔什是什么时候。我想我可能见过他几次，但他从来不在我的雷达范围内。但我们当时坐在那里听故事。伊莎贝尔坐在我腿上，盘腿坐着，你知道的。然后老师安布尔——这也是我们整个家庭背景故事的一部分了。孩子们超喜欢这个。老师安布尔，她简直就像是，如果你能把一个拥抱具象化成一个人类，她就是最可爱的人。她正在讲故事。她正在讲故事。
And he's like, yes, I was at that wedding. I'm like, I have no memory of you at that wedding. He's like, I have no memory of you at that wedding. Oh, my gosh. Like, we didn't speak. You have got to share that story with your kids someday. I think they would just get so tickled by it. Well, I will share it with them because it really is about how timing is everything.
然后她停了下来，看着一个小男孩，他正脸朝下舔地上的泥土。好吧。然后她说，嘿，杰克，泥土不是食物，好吗？所以我们不吃泥土。然后他抬起脸，嘴巴周围沾满了泥土。当时我想，哦，天哪，我永远不会忘记这个小孩。这小孩太搞笑了。然后，大约一年后，我去当志愿者。
Yeah. You know? Yeah. We just, we didn't see each other that way for many, many, many, many years until we were both ready. I love that because it's so true. I mean, for Josh and I, you know, it's so funny to me because I met Josh's oldest son before I met Josh. So our kids were at preschool together, and I was working on the office, so my call time was like 5.30 in the morning. So I could never drop Isabel off, but I would go and have lunch with her.
他们有一堆乐高积木，家长们自愿去搭建——你绝对不会相信这个——《星球大战》里的不同部件，比如飞船什么的。好吧。然后你会想，我来报名。我当时就想，我来报名。对，我乐高拼得超级烂，但我还是去志愿者拼一些《星球大战》的东西。
This was one of the great things is that I was often able to leave the set and go have lunch with her. And I would always arrive to her little preschool at story time. And they would sit in a circle under this big tree and have story time. It was the sweetest thing. And I remember the first time I met Jack. I don't remember the first time I met Josh. I guess I had met him a few times, but he's never on my radar. But we're sitting there for story time. And Isabel's sitting in my lap, like crisscross applesauce, you know. And the teacher, Amber, and this is part of our whole family lore now. The kids love this. The teacher Amber, who was just like, if you could manifest a hug into a human, she was just the most lovely person. She's reading her story. She's reading her story.
乔什当时在弄《星球大战》的东西，而且他拼得超级好。我猜他以前自愿来过好几次，但那是我唯一一次去。我拼乐高技术烂透了。他说他记得我拼得太烂了，以至于他们不得不回去重新拆掉重做我拼的一些部分。不过，总之，我记得当时觉得，哦，这是个不错的人。然后我开始把这些点连起来，心想，哦，那是杰克的爸爸。太好了。然后又是这样，依然不在我的雷达范围内。
and she stops, and she looks at a little boy who is face down licking the dirt on the ground. Okay. And then she goes, hey, Jack, dirt is not food, okay? So we're not going to eat the dirt. And he kind of raises his face up, and he's got, like, dirt around his mouth. And I was like, oh, my gosh, like, I'll never forget this kid. This kid is so funny. Then, like, a year later, I go to volunteer.
我当时，一直在旅行。我去了欧洲，然后回来了。这大概是几个月之后的事了。我在我常去的杂货店，就是我社区里的那家杂货店。我推着购物车转过拐角。差一点撞到乔什。我以前从来没在我的杂货店见过他。然后他说，哦，你知道吗，我搬家了，我现在住在这个社区。然后，你知道的，我们都是单亲父母，所以我们稍微聊了一下这个。我只是顺便跟他说了一句，嘿，你知道的，我要办个生日派对，如果你想来得话。然后他说，好啊。现在乔什以为我是邀请他去参加一个成年人的生日派对。我没想到要提一下，我让伊莎贝尔那天帮我策划生日派对，因为我其实并不在意。那又不是什么大整岁生日。而且伊莎贝尔超级喜欢小美人鱼，她喜欢美人鱼，所以她和我的朋友米卡——你知道的，他就像是她洛杉矶的叔叔那种角色，你知道的，他是我挚友之一——他帮伊莎贝尔为我策划了这个派对，因为她当时只有四岁左右，你知道的。对的，这完全是一个美人鱼主题的派对。我还告诉伊莎贝尔她可以邀请……
They had a bunch of Legos and parents. volunteered to build, you will not believe this, different pieces of the Star Wars, like ships and stuff. Okay. Yeah. And you're like, I'll sign that. I was like, I'll sign up. Yeah, I'm horrible at Legos, but I'll go volunteer to build some Star Wars stuff.
她所有的朋友，所以这真的可以变成她的派对。对的，所以她邀请了所有的朋友。那是一个游泳派对。我订了一个美人鱼主题的生日蛋糕。然后乔什来到了我家，他穿得超级可爱。而且，因为那是下午晚些时候的游泳派对，为了不让太阳太毒。所以大约下午4点开始。你知道的？因为我想着我要照顾这些年幼的孩子。
And Josh was working on the Star Wars stuff and he's really good. I guess he'd been volunteering a few times, but it was the only time I went. I was horrible at Legos. He said he remembers that I was so bad that they had to go back and redo like some of my build. But anyway, and I remember being like, oh, that's a nice person. And then I started realizing connecting the dots, like, oh, that's Jack's dad. That's so nice. Then again, not on my radar.
当时乔希在做《星球大战》相关的项目，他真的很擅长。我想他之前做过几次志愿者，但那是我唯一去的一次。我拼乐高技术极烂。他说他记得我技术太差了，以至于他们不得不回去重做我的一些作品。但不管怎样，我记得当时觉得，哦，这是个好人。然后我开始把这些线索串联起来，比如，哦，那是杰克的爸爸。真好。然后，依然没引起我的注意。
I was, like, traveling. I went to Europe and I got back. This is like months and months later. And I'm at my grocery store, like my neighborhood grocery store, I always go. And I turn the corner with my cart. And I almost run into Josh. And I'd never seen him at my grocery store before. And he said, oh, you know, I just want you.
我当时在旅行。我去了欧洲，然后回来了。这大概是好几个月之后的事了。我在杂货店，就像我常去的那个社区杂货店一样。我推着购物车转过拐角。差点撞上乔希。我以前从来没在我的杂货店见过他。他说，哦，你知道，我只是想……
know, I moved and I'm in this neighborhood now. And, you know, we were both single parenting, so we talked a little bit about that. And I just mentioned to him that I was like, hey, you know, I'm having a birthday party if you'd like to come. And he was like, sure. Now Josh thought I was inviting him like to an adult birthday party. I didn't think to mention that I let Isabelle plan my birthday party that year because I didn't really care. It wasn't a big number. And Isabel loved the little mermaid and she loved mermaids so her and my friend micha micka you know he's like her sort of like l.A uncle you know he's one of my dear friends he helped isabel plan this party for me because she was like four years old you know yes it was full mermaid theme i also told isabel she could invite
你知道，我搬家了，现在住在这个社区。而且，你知道，我们都是单亲父母，所以我们稍微聊了聊这个。我只是顺便跟他说，嘿，你知道，我要办一个生日派对，如果你想来的话。他当时说，好啊。现在乔希以为我是邀请他去参加一个成人的生日派对。我没想到要提一下，我那年让我女儿伊莎贝尔帮我筹划生日派对，因为我其实不在乎。又不是什么大寿。而且伊莎贝尔非常喜欢小美人鱼，她喜欢美人鱼，所以她和我的朋友米卡——你知道的，他有点像是她在洛杉矶的叔叔，你知道的，他是我最亲爱的朋友之一——他帮伊莎贝尔为我策划了这个派对，因为她当时才四岁左右，你知道的，是的，完全是美人鱼主题的。我还告诉伊莎贝尔，她可以邀请
all of her friends that it really it could be her party yeah so she invited all of her friends It was a swim party. I got a mermaid-themed birthday cake. And Josh arrives to my house, and he's dressed really cute. And he, because it was a swim party in the late afternoon, so the sun wouldn't be too hot. So it started at like 4 p.m. You know? Because I'm thinking I have these young kids.
她所有的朋友，这真的可以变成她的派对，是的，所以她邀请了所有的朋友。那是一个泳池派对。我订了一个美人鱼主题的生日蛋糕。乔希来到我家，他穿得非常可爱。而且他……因为那是一个下午晚些时候的泳池派对，这样太阳就不会太晒了。所以派对大约从下午4点开始。你知道吗？因为我在想我带着这些小孩子。
I don't want him to get sunburn. Anyway, Josh arrives around 4.30-ish, and he walks in dressed really nice with a bottle of wine. Of course. He's coming to your birthday. Yes. And he walks out. And I had a few. It was all moms, you know, like moms and their kids mostly.
我不想让他晒伤。总之，乔什在大约四点半左右到了，他穿得很帅，还带了一瓶酒。当然了。他是来参加你的生日的。对。然后他进来了。而我喝了一点。现场全都是妈妈，你知道的，基本上就是妈妈和她们的孩子。
And like I had invited my ex-husband and his fiancé, you know. And they're like, what is Josh doing here with a bottle of wine? Like who is this guy with a bottle of wine? And he said that it was like a record scratch for him. He walked out and he was like, oh. she like wasn't like he thought maybe at the grocery store I was kind of maybe flirty like hey do you want to come to my but I was just like do you want to come you? You were just being Angela you were just yes you live nearby you should come to my house for party this is so you yes and he said he felt so awkward and he
我还邀请了我的前夫和他的未婚夫，你知道的。他们当时就在想，乔什带着一瓶酒来这里干什么？这拿着酒的家伙到底是谁？乔什说，对他来说当时就像是唱片播放时突然卡壳了一声。他走进来，然后心想，哦。她当时……不像他想的那样，他可能以为我在杂货店时有点像是在调情，比如“嘿，你想来参加我的……”但其实我只是说“你想来吗？”你只是在做安吉拉，你只是——是的，你住在附近，你应该来我家参加派对，这太像你的风格了——是的，他说他当时觉得太尴尬了，他
could not wait to get out of there he only stayed for like 30 minutes and then he was like all right well I'm going to go where should I leave the wine and I'm like oh you know near the craft table I don't You know, it was such like a kid party. But that is the moment that I like sort of saw him, you know? That's what I was going to ask you. Yes. Like when he showed up thinking nice, this might be, you see him and be like, oh, oh, he's thinking, well, oh, okay, wait. Yes, it was exactly that. So it was like a long time, like much later that finally we went out to dinner. and went and saw a movie and that was like kind of like oh okay this is this is a date so sweet I know so sweet I love that kids your friendly nature Star Wars mermaids are all part of that story I know and you know I do like really empathize when people share their meat cutts like some of them
简直迫不及待地想离开那里，他只待了大约30分钟，然后他就说，好吧，我要走了，酒我放哪儿？我说，哦，你知道的，就放在手工艺桌旁边吧。我……你知道的，这真是一个儿童派对。但就是在那一刻，我仿佛真正“注意到”了他，你知道吗？这就是我想问你的。是的。就好像他精心打扮着出现，心想，这可能会有戏，你看到他然后心想，哦，哦，他在想，嗯，哦，好吧，等等。是的，完全就是这样。所以过了很久，过了很久以后，我们才终于一起去吃晚饭，去看了一场电影，然后那种感觉就是，哦，好吧，这才是真正的约会。太甜了。我知道，真的太甜了。我太喜欢了，孩子们、你友善的性格、星球大战、美人鱼，这些都是这个故事的一部分。我知道，而且你知道吗，当人们分享他们的“初次相遇”故事时，我真的很有共鸣，因为其中有些故事
are like oh this was so long it's like how do you put that in a soundbook you know like yeah that's just life and how it unfolds and it's it's not always just immediate sometimes things that are really worth something play out over time yeah uh I just have a smile on my face I love talking about love I do too I love it so much I love it so much I just want to thank everyone who wrote in you know this was such a fun episode to do and thank you Jenna for prompting us to watch great rom-coms. Well, we hope you have a really good week. Please be sure to check out the How We Made Your Mother podcast now on Office Ladies Network and available wherever you get your podcasts. I mean, that's really a whole TV show about
就像是，哦，这经历太漫长了，就像是，你怎么能把这些塞进一个有声书中呢，你知道的——是的，生活就是这样，它就是这样展开的，而且它并不总是那么立竿见影，有时真正有价值的事情需要时间慢慢发展。是的，我脸上一直挂着微笑，我太喜欢谈论爱情了。我也是，我太喜欢了，我真的太喜欢了。我只想感谢所有写信来的朋友，你知道的，这一期节目做起来太有趣了，谢谢詹娜启发我们去观看精彩的浪漫喜剧。嗯，我们希望大家有一个愉快的一周。请务必收听现在已在 Office Ladies Network 上线并在各大播客平台播出的 How We Made Your Mother 播客。我的意思是，那真的整整是一部关于浪漫初遇的电视剧。
a meet-cute romance. It is, and so fun, too. All right, we'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
确实是的，而且非常有趣。好了，我们下次再见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 是 Audacy 的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audacy 的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。Office Ladies 的混音和母带制作由比尔·舒尔茨完成。
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是里德·勃拉姆森的 Ruppertree。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。